voilà je vous propose de commencer notre
audition audition commune entre la
commission des affaires économiques et
la Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
et nous sommes très heureux d'accueillir
dans cet enceinte de la salle Médicis
monsieur Rodolphe Saad le président
directeur général de CMA CGM monsieur le
Président Directeur Général monsieur le
Président Longeot mes chers collègues
merci infiniment à vous monsieur
Rodolphe Saadet d'avoir accepté cette
audition et la présence fort nombreuses
de nos collègues témoignent de l'intérêt
qu'il porte à pouvoir vous entendre et
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions je vous prie en premier lieu
de bien vouloir excuser la présidente de
la commission des affaires économiques
Sophie prima elle a été retenue dans son
département par des obsèques je sais
qu'elle a beaucoup œuvré pour que vous
puissiez venir ici au Sénat et être bien
sûr en audition qu'elle aurait vivement
souhaité être là et que j'ai la charge
et la responsabilité de pouvoir suppléer
à son absence aujourd'hui le groupe CMA
CGM compagnie maritime d'affritement
Compagnie Générale maritime étant
fleuron français et le beau succès d'une
entreprise familiale ancrée à Marseille
sur le port de la Joliette dans la tour
Zaha Hadid premier armateur français et
troisième armateur mondial de portes
cantonaire votre chiffre d'affaires
s'élève à 50 milliards d'euros en 2021
et vous employez la bagatelle de 160
000 salariés dans le monde pour une
flotte de près de 600 navires
je voudrais d'abord revenir sur le
contexte pour le moins incertain dans
lequel votre groupe est parvenu à se
développer les restrictions aux échanges
pendant la pandémie de la covid-19 ont
été un test de résilience majeur pour
une entreprise comme la vôtre qui joue
un rôle absolument central dans la
mondialisation des échanges on prédisait
des lendemains difficiles pour le
transport maritime international avec
une activité durablement atrophiée or il
n'en a rien été on a plutôt connu des
embouteillages des pénuries et des
hausses de prix avec une croissance de
8% de la demande de conteneur au premier
trimestre 2021
mais s'agissait-il d'un simple rebond
lié à la reconstitution de stock il
semble que depuis peu l'on revienne à
des volumes plus classiques on a
enregistré au premier trimestre 2022 une
baisse de la demande mondiale de
conteneur de
1%. est-ce un simple retour aux
tendances normales du commerce mondial
est-ce du au ralentissement industriel
de la chute de la Chine ou est-ce due au
contraire à des problématiques
logistiques par exemple une forme de
congestion de nos pores ou une hausse
des tarifs de fret dans un contexte
d'inflation
porté par cette conjoncture CMA CGM est
devenu en 2021 l'entreprise française
qui a dégagé le plus de bénéfices 18
milliards de dollars devant total
énergie et il est dit que l'année 2022
sera encore meilleur au premier
trimestre vous avez affiché un
spectaculaire bénéfice net de 7,2
milliards de dollars pour un chiffre
d'affaires de
18,2 milliards de dollars en hausse de
70%. aussi ma deuxième question porte
sur les origines de ces bénéfices qui
ont suscité de nombreux commentaires
voir des propositions de taxation des
profits considérés comme des supers
profits
dans ce contexte vous avez annoncé à
compter du premier août prochain des
mesures ciblées pour contribuer à
l'effort de modération des prix à la
consommation pour les ménages français
en complément d'un gel des taux de fret
déjà décidé à l'automne pour les
contrats spot de court terme qui
représentent 20% de vos activités
à nouveau ces mesures consisteraient en
des baisses de taux de fret 500 euros
pour un conteneur 40 pieds mais
uniquement pour les importations de la
grande distribution en France pour les
outre-mer toutes les importations sont
concernées pourriez-vous monsieur le
Président Directeur Général détaillé
l'articulation de ces mesures ciblées
avec les précédentes et leur durée
d'application cela signifie-t-il que
dans certains cas vous devrez travailler
à prix coûtant voir à perte surtout quel
est l'impact attendu de ces réductions
d'abord sur la chaîne logistique et
ensuite sur le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs pourriez-vous si tenter
que cela soit possible nous détailler la
composante transport maritime dans le
prix de vente de produits emblématiques
que vous transportez et en particulier
pour les biens de première nécessité
pour beaucoup en effet l'impression et
que ce coût reste marginal dans le coup
total comparé par exemple au coût de
production mais aussi aux autres coups
logistiques coût de stockage coût de
manutention portuaire coût de transport
routier
et à propos de la chaîne logistique
j'aimerais maintenant m'attarder sur
votre stratégie de diversification de
vos activités
traditionnellement centrée sur le
transport maritime vous avez initié une
concentration verticale à mon et à Val
par des acquisitions hors de votre cœur
de métier en diversifiant vos activités
pour vous rapprocher du consommateur
rachat de CVA logistique en 2019
spécialiste des entrepôts rachat de
colis privés concurrents de la Poste
dans les livraisons en février
2022 au-delà du transport maritime vous
êtes ainsi devenu un acteur à part
entière de la logistique terrestre votre
but est-il de maîtriser l'ensemble de la
chaîne logistique pour sécuriser vos
activités traditionnelles ou
cherchez-vous au contraire à vous
déplacer peu à peu vers Laval dont on
imagine qu'il connaît des taux de marge
plus importants par ailleurs vous avez
conclu un partenariat avec Air France
KLM en devenant son actionnaire
stratégique via une montée à son capital
à hauteur de 9 % soit 400 millions
d'euros champion européen du fret vous
compléterez votre flotte de
porte-conteneur par une flotte d'avion
cargo sur quelle analyse des évolutions
du commerce mondial cette entrée au
capital se fond de tel quel sera la
temporalité du redressement d'Air France
KLM pardon dont on sait qu'il doit
encore rembourser un quart des aides
d'État dont il a pu bénéficier durant la
crise
enfin j'aimerais terminer par une
réflexion plus prospective et plus
générale sur les évolutions du commerce
extérieur notre commission des affaires
économiques vient de publier un rapport
sur la souveraineté économique et
certains voient prendre une
régionalisation du commerce puisque
plusieurs états cherchent un raccourcir
les chaînes de valeur voire à les
relocaliser or nous avons acquis la
conviction que l'un des leviers pour
renforcer notre souveraineté économique
et la diversification de nos
fournisseurs et de nos sources
d'approvisionnement à ce jour vous
desservez 420 ports dans le monde mais
on sait que certains gros pores
concentrent l'essentiel des flux par
exemple en Europe Rotterdam envers ou Le
Havre ou en Chine Shanghai dans quelle
mesure pouvez-vous être un acteur à part
entière de cette stratégie de
diversification vous paraît-elle
économiquement viable et rentable ou les
économies d'échelle rendent-elles cette
diversification peut crédible jeunesse
maintenant la parole au président de la
Commission de la management du
territoire et du développement durable
président de l'anjo je sais qu'il va
entre autres vous interroger sur
l'impact carbone de vos activités ou sur
les aspects plus spécifiquement
portuaires
merci madame la Présidente merci chers
collègues mais mes chers collègues
nous accueillons aujourd'hui monsieur
Rodolphe Saad qui est à la tête non
seulement d'un fleuron économie
française mais d'un des leaders mondiaux
du fret maritime aux côtés de marks Line
et de MSC je pense que mes collègues
sont d'autant plus satisfaits de cette
opportunité que la commission
d'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable que je préside
n'avait-il me semble pas eu l'occasion
d'entendre la GMA j'ai la CMA CGM dans
le cadre de la mission d'information
lancé en son sein sur la performance et
la gouvernance des ports maritimes
français
je rappelle que ces travaux ont donnés
lieu à l'adoption par le Sénat fin 2020
d'une proposition de loi de Michel
vaspar comportant près de 20 mesures
destinées à moderniser nos ports et à
mieux armer et les armées de face à la
compétition internationale mais
venons-en au vif du sujet la commission
des affaires économiques que je remercie
d'avoir pris l'initiative de cette
audition
vous interrogera sans doute monsieur le
Président sur la stratégie de votre
groupe son rôle dans l'évolution récente
du commerce mondial ou encore votre
contribution à l'effort de modération
des prix à la consommation pour les
ménages à travers la baisse de vos taux
de fret notre nos commissaire ont
également de nombreux sujets à aborder
avec vous s'agissant par exemple de
votre stratégie en matière de
multimodalisme de l'attractivité du
pavillon français et de nos ports
maritimes ou encore des enjeux de
décarbonation du secteur
je laisserai également Philippe Tabarro
et Évelyne Perrault qui sont
respectivement rapporteur pour avis dans
le cadre du budget sur le transport
maritime et aérien vous interrogez sur
la stratégie de diversification qui a
conduit votre groupe à se lancer dans le
fer aérien
avant toute chose monsieur le Président
je souhaiterais faire un état des lieux
du fret maritime qui subit une forte
pression depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire il a connu un important
ralentissement du fait des restrictions
sanitaires prises au cours de premier
semestre 2020 suivi d'un rebond brutal
qui a désorganisé le marché en
entraînant une pénurie pénurie de
conteneurs et mécaniquement une flambée
des prix
monsieur le Président pourriez-vous nous
dire où en est le transport maritime de
marchandises en ce début de deuxième
semestre 2020
quels sont les points de tension que ce
qui subit substit qui substite dans le
monde des routes maritimes et dans les
ports quand pouvons-nous espérer une
normalisation normalisation du trafic je
souhaiterais également que vous évoquiez
les conséquences du conflit en Ukraine
sur le trafic maritime que ce soit à
travers la hausse des prix du carburant
ou de l'engorgement de certains ports du
nord de l'Europe comme la CMA CGM
s'est-elle organisée face à cette crise
alors que les russes et ukrainiens
représentent près de 15% des effectifs
de la marine marchande mondiale le
secteur risque-t-il de rencontrer des
difficultés de main d'oeuvre
enfin pourriez-vous faire un point sur
la flotte de CMA CGM on nous indiquant
le nombre de navires porte-conteneurs
que vous détenez l'évolution de votre
flotte ces dernières années
pouvez-vous plus particulièrement nous
indiquer qu'elle part de vos navires est
immatriculée au régime français et si
selon vous le cadre fiscal actuel
devrait être réformé pour rendre le
pavillon français plus attractif enfin
je souhaite évoquer les récents accords
passés par la CMA CGM notamment à Kenji
et WF
en faveur de la décarbonation du
transport maritime pouvez-vous nous dire
un mot sur ces partenariats et nous dire
où en est votre groupe en matière
d'intégration de technologie de
propulsion peu carbonée dans sa flotte
parmi les technologies actuellement
disponibles lesquelles vous semblent les
plus prometteuses à court et moyen terme
pour la marine marchande je vous
remercie et je vais céder la parole à
nos collègues
oui merci cher président donc nous
allons bien évidemment monsieur le
Président Directeur Général vous laissez
la parole comme c'est la première fois
que vous voudrez à ce genre d'exercice
donc bien sûr vous avez toute latitude
pour à la fois répondre aux questions
que nous venons déjà de vous poser à la
fois Jean-François Longeot et moi-même
et bien évidemment pour nous exposer
aujourd'hui votre stratégie et puis
ensuite nous ouvrirons le débat auprès
de nos collègues et comme vous l'avez
souhaité et j'en informe nos collègues
nous procéderons questions après
question c'est à dire que une question
sera posée par un collègue de la
commission des affaires économiques
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
y répondra et ensuite ça sera une
question du côté de la commission
d'aménagement du territoire et on
procédera ainsi jusqu'à la fin de
l'audition monsieur sad c'est à vous de
prendre la parole
merci beaucoup madame la vice-présidente
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateur
c'est un grand honneur de m'exprimer
aujourd'hui devant la représentation
nationale et je vous remercie de cette
invitation
comme vous l'avez souhaité mon proposera
à clarifier la situation les enjeux et
les perspectives du secteur de la
logistique je le ferai à partir de
l'exemple et de l'expérience d'une
entreprise française et familiale une
entreprise qui a quand moins de 50 ans
d'existence et devenu le leader mondial
du transport et de la logistique qui
couvre aujourd'hui toute la chaîne
logistique du premier au dernier
kilomètre
son succès à une histoire qui croise
l'histoire d'une famille de la France et
de la mondialisation ces 50 dernières
années
cette histoire c'est celle de la CMA CGM
permet moi de vous la raconter car elle
peut vous aider à comprendre comment la
France pourra à l'avenir garder sa place
au premier rang de l'économie mondiale
le succès de notre groupe repose sur un
principe très fort qui est celui de
l'investissement
c'était déjà le coeur de la vision que
portait le fondateur de notre compagnie
mon père Jacques Sade lorsqu'il a fut la
guerre au Liban pour venir s'installer
en France j'avais 8 ans
mon père a choisi Marseille car cette
ville lui rappelait Beyrouth
nous devions y rester quelques semaines
nous y sommes depuis plus de 44 ans
car Jacques sad a fait le pari
d'investir en France en septembre 1978
il a créé la CM1 la compagnie maritime
d'affrètement avec une double intuition
d'abord une vision de l'avenir Jacques
Sade était convaincu qu'avec la
mondialisation les échanges par voie
maritimes allaient se développer et que
le conteneur y occuperait une place pour
prépondérante
pourquoi le conteneur
il avait découvert cette boîte
métallique lors d'un stage aux
États-Unis l'armée américaine l'utiliser
pour acheminer son matériel au Vietnam
j'ai accès à des anticipé son immense
potentiel l'avenir lui a donné raison
à cette anticipation s'ajoute l'ambition
d'anticiper l'explosion future de la
mondialisation
à la création la CMA c'était quatre
collaborateurs et un seul et unique
bateau en location qui reliait Marseille
Livourne l'attaquer et Beyrouth
aujourd'hui nous comptons 150 000
collaborateurs
570 navires
580 entrepôts et 6 avions cargo
la CMA se jette se développe en même
temps en même temps que la
mondialisation s'intensifie d'abord sur
le plan géographique en s'ouvrant
l'accès à de nouvelles zones via le
canal de Suez en 1983 et trois ans plus
tard vers l'Asie ce qui nous a permis
d'ouvrir en 1992 le premier bureau de
CMA en CHINE à Shanghai presque 10 ans
avant l'entrée à l'OMC de cette Chine
dont mon père pressenté qu'elle
deviendrait l'usine du monde ensuite sur
le plan capitalistique en 96 nous avons
acheté et redressé la compagnie
nationale CGM
héritière de la transatlantique avant de
fusionner pour donner naissance au
premier armateur français en 2005 avec
le rachat de Delmas CMA CGM est devenu
le numéro 3 mondial du transport
maritime par conteneur
dans un secteur où les cycliques les
profits sont cycliques l'entreprise a
toujours maintenu le cap de
l'investissement dans les moments
favorables comme dans les moments
difficiles
d'un côté entre 2000 et 2008 portés par
une croissance annuelle de près de 20%
nous avons étendu notre réseau
commercial et nos lignes maritimes en
couvrant 420 ports sur les cinq
continents d'un autre côté lorsque la
crise de 2008 a frappé l'ensemble de
l'économie mondiale et particulièrement
le secteur des échanges notre groupe a
bien évidemment connu de grandes
difficultés
mais alors que beaucoup parier sur notre
dépôt de bilan nous avons tenu bon notre
objectif d'investissement en faisant
entrer au capital de notre compagnie à
la fois un groupe industriel familial
turc ilirime et la BPI à l'époque FSI la
BPI nous accompagne depuis lors et
concerne une participation symbolique de
3% et un siège à notre conseil
d'administration
lorsque les échanges mondiaux ont repris
notre groupe était en mesure d'entamer
une nouvelle phase de son histoire
ainsi nous avons pu affermir notre place
notre place pardon de leaders en
rachetant certains de nos concurrents
asiatiques comme en 2015 le singapouria
à Noël qui fait de nous le leader entre
l'Asie et les États-Unis
l'année suivante nous avons signé avec
des armateurs asiatiques
océans alliance un accord de partenariat
à long terme pour tarder l'espace
aborder navire qui nous permet d'opérer
des bateaux plus grands afin de
renforcer à la fois notre compétitivité
et de solidifier
nous solidifier face aux aléas du marché
lorsque j'ai pris la direction générale
et la présidence du groupe en 2017 ma
priorité a été densité d'anticiper les
évolutions de la supply chain
j'ai alors décidé de me diversifier dans
la logistique et d'offrir à nos clients
une solution complète qui couvre
l'ensemble de leurs besoins
nous avons alors acheté le groupe suisse
s'éva logistique 12e mondial qui propose
notamment le transport aérien routier
ferroviaire et de l'entreposage
ma première décision a été de rapatrier
cette entreprise en France à Marseille
où nous avons créé 200 emplois
supplémentaires et progressivement
redresser seva pour en faire un leader
mondial de la logistique
vous avez cherché également à renforcer
dans ces métiers par des achats ciblés
la société d'entreposage américaine
Ingram reconnu pour la logistique de
l'e-commerce en 2021 puis Colis Privé
pour couvrir le dernier kilomètre et
tout récemment nous avons racheté le
transporteur automobile Gefco à son
actionnaire russe
rachat réalisé en un temps record en
raison de la guerre ce qui nous a permis
de protéger Gefco en le faisant revenir
sous pavillon français et de sauvegarder
plus de 10000 emplois dont 3500 en
France enfin nous avons étendu nos
activités au fret aérien en créant l'an
dernier notre propre division CMA CGM
air cargo
nous avons acquis nos propres avions
quatre et abus à 330 cargo et deux
Boeing triple 7 cargo deux autres sont
en commande ainsi que 4 Airbus A350
cargo nous avons également développé une
alliance stratégique et commerciale avec
Air France KLM pour mutualiser les
soutes de nos avions c'est un secteur
crucial pour offrir de nouvelles
solutions express à nos clients dans le
contexte de tension que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui et nous avons choisi de
devenir leur actionnaire à hauteur de
9%, ce qui fait de nous le numéro 1 du
fret aérien et le numéro 4
au niveau mondial le développement du
fret contribuera à leur redressement
vous me permettrez de m'arrêter quelques
instants sur ces tensions qui frappent
actuellement les chaînes logistiques
mondiales car elles sont riches
d'enseignement pour l'avenir vous l'avez
souligné madame la vice-présidente notre
secteur a connu des tensions inédites au
cours de ces deux dernières années sous
l'effet de la crise sanitaire de la
forte reprise économique qui a suivi les
confinements et dans une certaine mesure
de la guerre en Ukraine elles se sont
traduites par certaines distributions
des chaînes logistiques et par les
difficultés d'approvisionnement pour les
entreprises
je voudrais vous livrer mon analyse de
cette situation avant dans livrer
quelques enseignements
revenons à février 2020 avant la mise en
place du premier confinement le commerce
international a connu un fort
ralentissement la plupart des
entreprises notamment en France avait
soit de fermer leur porte soit fortement
ralenti leur activité
nous avons ajusté nos capacités en
ralentissant nos navires et en jouant
sur le levier des navires affréter pour
réduire nos capacités sauf et je tiens à
le souligner pour les outre-mer
ou tout nos services ont été maintenus
même si la remplissage était à peine à
65%
dès le quatrième trimestre 2020 la
demande de transport est repartie avec
vigueur avec une production très forte
les politiques dit des différents
gouvernements ont soutenu cette
consommation privée de déplacement les
consommateurs se sont reportés sur
l'achat de bien manufacturés
principalement en provenance d'Asie la
pandémie et la digitalisation ont
favorisé le boom de l'e-commerce qui est
une tendance de fond ce qui a intensifié
les flux logistiques mondiaux
les volumes du marché ont ainsi
fortement augmenté en 2020 plus 12% au
global plus 10% sur le marché Asie
Europe plus 18% sur le marché
transpacifique et plus 16% sur le marché
transatlantique
personne n'avait anticipé la forte
reprise qui a suivi le premier
confinement
l'industrie maritime a certes réagi
rapidement et CMA c'est gemmes plus
encore le secteur a augmenté ses
capacités de 8% en moyenne depuis le
début de la crise nous de 18% nous avons
renforcé nos infrastructures par de
nouveaux terminaux FMS à Los Angeles Abu
Dhabi Alexandrie Beyrouth et
dernièrement n'ava Sheva qui est le port
de Bombay en Inde nous avons acheté ou
commander 137 navires la même année
et fait entrer en flotte plus de 500 000
conteneurs en 2020
nous avons particulièrement veillé à
trouver des solutions à tous nos clients
en France ce dont témoignent la
progression de nos volumes à l'import
plus 30% d'augmentation par rapport à
2019 pour y parvenir à l'approche des
fêtes de fin d'année nous avons affrété
trois navires supplémentaires pour le
marché français spécialement
ainsi vous le voyez nous avons répondu
rapidement et fortement mais dans des
conditions aussi difficiles on ne peut
pas être les seuls visés malgré tout ce
qui s'est passé d'abord parce que
l'ajustement entre les capacités et la
demande à prix du temps ensuite nous
avions beau augmenté nos capacités
disponibles la capacité dynamique réelle
plafonnée particulièrement pour la
filière du conteneur en raison du temps
immobilisation des navires de commerce
on estime qu'en 2021 la congestion à
elle seule à absorber 17% des capacités
mondiales
mais les transporteurs maritimes de
détenaient qu'une partie de la solution
car ce sont en réalité les
infrastructures terrestres notamment
portuaires qui ont été saturés avec un
pic de congestion fin 2021 ou début 2022
selon les régions du monde où vous
donnez quelques exemples jusqu'à 20
jours d'attente à Los Angeles en janvier
2022 jusqu'à 24 jours à Seattle en 2021
deux raisons qui expliquent cela des
infrastructures portuaires
sous-dimensionnées et des pénuries de
main d'oeuvre ou conjoncturelles par les
dockers mis en quarantaine suite à la
crise du covid
je note depuis quelques semaines un
ralentissement de la croissance les
stocks sont conséquents un peu partout
dans le monde et la consommation faiblit
certains évoquent une récession
je parlerai plutôt d'un atterrissage en
douceur de la normalisation des flux ce
qui fera nécessairement baissé le prix
du fret
nous sommes soumis à la loi de l'offre
et de la demande à la hausse comme à la
baisse
de cette crise on peut tirer certains
nombres d'enseignements qui concernent
les échanges mondiaux mais qui engagent
aussi la décision politique le premier
me semble aujourd'hui appelé à certaines
réformes la résilience des chaînes
d'approvisionnement passe par la mise en
place d'infrastructures terrestres et
notamment portuaire
les adapter et les rendre plus
performantes il faut pouvoir gérer les
pics de demande à terre également je
rejoins aussi les conclusions du rapport
remis par le sénateur Vespa il
préconisait que les ports français
réfléchissent à leur avenir pour notre
part nous sommes bien évidemment plus
couverts à participer et à contribuer et
à contribuer à cette réflexion
le deuxième enseignement concerne la
stratégie des entreprises
les crises récentes notamment la
paillote de pandémie et la guerre en
Ukraine ont confirmé notre vision et la
validité des choix opérés par notre
groupe et non accéléré des tendances que
nous avions enclenché
c'est parce que nous avions préparé
l'avenir par nos investissements que
nous avons pu en cinq ans de 2017 à 2022
passer de 37000 collaborateurs à 150 000
collabeurs aux gens de collaborateurs
aujourd'hui et de tripler notre chiffre
d'affaires de 21 milliards de dollars à
56 milliards de dollars aujourd'hui
tout au long de son histoire notre
groupe a souvent été décrit de façon
variable
tant au vu comme trop endetté
tantôt comme trop profitable la vérité
c'est qu'il a toujours investi le fil
conducteur de son histoire comme de son
succès ce sont les investissements
90% de nos bénéfices sont réinvestis
ainsi nos bénéfices d'aujourd'hui sont
le fruit de nos investissements d'hier
et ce sont aussi les germes de nos
investissements pour demain
le troisième enseignement
concerne le rôle que peut jouer un
leader mondial français en période de
crise
et je souhaite rappeler combien notre
engagement a été exemplaire tout au long
de la crise
issue de la pandémie en mettant à
l'honneur la mobilisation de toutes les
équipes du groupe CMA CGM
conscient que le leadership s'accompagne
d'une grande responsabilité dès le début
du covid nous nous sommes collectivement
mobilisés pour les populations
fragilisées par la crise sanitaire nous
avons acheminé plus de 800 millions de
masques vers la France en deux mois et
nous avons donné plus d'un million de
masques aux structures sanitaires de
différents pays la France des États-Unis
le Liban l'Algérie la Côte d'Ivoire le
Nigéria la Mauritanie le Sénégal et le
Cameroun avec accent contre la fin et
l'UNICEF nous avons distribué des kits
sanitaires à 5000 personnes sans abri
ainsi que de la nourriture pour les
jeunes enfants et nourrissons à
Marseille avec la Banque Alimentaire
nous avons offert 6 tonnes de denrées
pour 12000 familles et nous avons
également mené de nombreuses autres
actions
et aujourd'hui encore face à l'inflation
et aux difficultés de pouvoir d'achat
CMA CGM a montré son esprit de
responsabilité avec une intention
particulière en France pour les
outre-mer les PME et le pouvoir d'achat
des consommateurs
nous avons été le premier transporteur
maritime en avril 2021 à gelé les tarifs
de fret spot pour les outre-mer et en
septembre 2021 pour la métropole
depuis l'été dernier nous avons réservé
des capacités à tarif réduit pour les
PME exportatrices françaises cela
représente un volume d'environ 500
conteneurs par semaine
nous le transportons ni blé ni pétrole
ni gaz notre impact sur l'inflation et
donc très faible le coût du transport ne
représente que 4% du coût d'un produit
en moyenne selon une étude réalisée par
Barclays en janvier dernier il faut donc
garder le sens de la mesure dans ce qui
est demandé à notre secteur
parce que nous sommes un groupe engagé
nous avons de nous-mêmes proposé de
diminuer le coût de certains transports
pour aider les consommateurs français
nous avons annoncé fin juin baisser de
500 euros par conteneur pour toutes les
importations dans les DOM-TOM ainsi que
les importations en métropole de 14
principaux distributeurs français
cette baisse sera effective à partir du
1er août pour une durée d'un an
mais nous voulons être sûr que ces
profits iront au consommateurs voilà
pourquoi nous avons demandé au service
du ministère de l'Économie d'évaluer
l'impact de cette mesure
enfin deux marchandises sur 3 en France
dans les containers ne sont pas
transportés par le groupe CMA CGM
cela signifie aussi que les autres
compagnies
doivent elles aussi
mettre en mettre mise pardon en face de
leur responsabilités
l'exemple la réalité d'une entreprise
n'est pas pour moi un idéal abstrait
mais une façon d'être
utile aux autres et au monde
j'ai toujours voulu que nos bénéfices
soient utiles
utile à notre transformation
utile aux valeurs que nous portons et
bien sûr utile à la France
en faisant le choix d'investir nos
profits dans le développement du groupe
nous avons construit un leader mondial
du transport et de la logistique depuis
la France et en France
alors que nous ne réalisons qu'une
faible partie de notre chiffre
d'affaires nous avons toujours assumé
notre responsabilité particulière
vis-à-vis de la France nous avons
notamment
œuvré à développer l'emploi nous avons
doublé nos effectifs en France en 5 ans
notre groupe est par ailleurs soumis
d'une part à l'impôt sur les sociétés
classiques pour nous activités
logistiques et portuaires et d'une autre
part à une fiscalité européenne à
travers la taxe automnale ce système
d'imposition a permis de préserver en
Europe les grandes compagnies maritimes
mondiales et les emplois associés et de
contrer la montée en puissance des
compagnies asiatiques il est donc
crucial
pour nous que la France nous aide à
maintenir un jeu à armes égales entre
prestataires européens
par notre histoire nous avons aussi un
profond encrage dans le territoire à
Marseille où se trouve notre siège
social où nous employons le tiers de nos
salariés français plus de 3000 personnes
et où nous générons aussi 5000 emplois
indirects
afin de promouvoir l'innovation et
l'esprit entrepreneurial nous y avons
ouvert en 2018 un incubateur de start-up
the box qui se développe aussi à
l'international en Amérique dans la
Caraïbe
et en Afrique et nous ouvrirons en 2024
à Marseille un centre d'innovation et de
formation tangram pour inventer le
transport et la logistique durable de
demain avec d'autres grands groupes des
start-up et des chercheurs enfin notre
fondation d'entreprise aide plus de 75
associations à Marseille comme au Liban
et nous avons créé avec Aix-Marseille
Université une chaire médicale autour de
l'oncologie et de la neurologie vous
voyez l'ancrage local et pour nous le
vecteur d'un engagement humaniste
mondial
car malgré sa taille notre groupe est
resté profondément humain
sans doute parce que nous savons que les
échanges entre les êtres nourrissent
aussi les liens
c'est d'abord vrai dans l'entreprise
pour nous la richesse humaine de nos
équipes et notre plus belle actif
pour l'encourager nous pratiquons une
politique de redistribution active en
2021 suite au très bon résultat obtenu
par notre activité maritime nous avons
accordé à tous nos employés de cette
division dans le monde deux mois de
salaire supplémentaires auxquels se sont
ajoutés des augmentations et primes
représentant 11% de la masse salariale
et d'un intéressement équivalent à deux
mois de salaire pour nos collaborateurs
français enfin le mois dernier face à
l'inflation nous avons décidé d'allouer
à tous nos collaborateurs en France
touchant jusqu'à deux fois le SMIC une
prime de 4500 euros
ancré dans le territoire
forte de notre humanité nous nous sommes
aussi engagés pour la protection de
l'environnement dans lequel nous opérons
et dans lequel nous ne pourrions
poursuivre notre développement si les
critères ESG sont pour nous des
incubateurs des indicateurs pardon de
gestion essentielle nous faisons de la
transition énergétique un objectif de
notre transformation depuis longtemps
en ce domaine aussi nous avons été
pionniers nous avons été les premiers à
décider qu'aucun de nos navires ne
passerait pas la route du nord ouverte
certains mois de l'année en raison de la
fonte des glaces d'autres nous ont suivi
nous avons aussi été les premiers à
développer des navires propulsés au gaz
naturel et kifié qui seront depuis
devenus un standard dans l'industrie
nous en avons déjà 29
ils seront 77
d'ici 4 ans nos investissements dans la
recherche et notre engagement dans la
transition du rap du groupe nous ont
permis de développer l'usage du GNL
grâce à lui nous pouvons supprimer la
quasi-totalité des émissions de
particules fines et de réduire nos
émissions de CO2 de l'ordre de 20%. bien
sûr le GNL n'est qu'une énergie de
transition mais la technologie que nous
avons développée nous permettra
d'utiliser bientôt le biométhane et le
méthane de synthèse qui nous permettront
de réduire pour l'un d'au moins 67% nos
émissions de CO2 et pour l'autre 80% de
nos émissions
mais ces carburants n'existent pour
l'instant qu'en quantité très faible et
leur filière de production doivent être
renforcés j'ai donc décidé de créer une
division énergie dotée de moyens
significatifs et nous avons signé
plusieurs partenariats sur le sujet avec
engie par exemple nous allons investir
dans des sites de production d'eau
biométhane et de méthane de synthèse en
France notamment parallèlement nous
avons passé commande de navire propulsé
au méthanol nous travaillons au sein du
groupe à décarboné l'ensemble de nos
autres activités le transport routier
aérien ainsi que dans la logistique mais
nous voulons aussi contribuer à forger
un élan collectif qui fasse une vraie
différence voilà pourquoi nous avons
créé en 2020 une coalition regroupant 17
entreprises internationales
nous travaillons ensemble sur douche 12
projets concrets de l'électrification du
transport au projet de production de
biométhain liquéfier en passant par le
développement d'un biocarburant à partir
de déchets de bois
nous devons continuer collectivement à
identifier toutes les solutions pour
parvenir au net0 et les mettre en oeuvre
rapidement
cet engagement a été transformation
durable et cruciale pour moi pour
l'avenir de notre groupe mais aussi pour
la pérennité de notre secteur
l'exemplarité doit être une recherche
d'action à toutes les échelles par tous
les moyens
et avec toutes les parties prenantes
en conclusion
la crise
issue de la pandémie n'a pas fait naître
de nouvelles situations
mais elle a révélé que ces situations
étaient lattes pour notre entreprise
elle accéléré les orientations les
orientations stratégiques des gens en
cours sans modifier notre engagement de
fond nous n'avons cessé de nous
développer en réinvestissant la
quasi-totalité de nos profits dans le
développement de notre entreprise pour
offrir de nouvelles solutions à nos
clients et accélérer notre transition
énergétique c'est ce que je qualifierais
de bénéfices utiles
c'est bien cette politique de
réinvestissement dans l'entreprise qui
explique notre formidable développement
et qui légitime notre position des
leaders
pour notre pays la crise a été
l'occasion d'une salutaire mise en garde
le transport et la logistique sont des
activités et des outils stratégiques
pour un pays pour renforcer la
compétitivité et la souveraineté de la
France dans le secteur portuaire et
logistique il est donc nécessaire de
mettre en place avec les pouvoirs
publics un plan d'investissement
ambitieux nous sommes prêts à y
travailler avec vous
envisager à la fois le devenir de CMA
CGM et celui de la France tel a été le
cœur de mon analyse telle est aussi
l'ambition à laquelle je suis fier de
vrai
depuis sa fondation notre groupe
familial porte haut les couleurs de la
France et de ses valeurs dans la
mondialisation il contribuer aussi par
ces quelques pistes est un grand honneur
madame la vice-présidente monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs je suis
à votre disposition pour apporter des
prépositions et de répondre aux
questions que vous pourriez avoir merci
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Directeur Général et les
applaudissements qui ont suivi votre
intervention témoignent en tout cas de
l'intérêt comporté l'ensemble de nos
collègues à la présentation très claire
très précise de votre groupe mais aussi
à son développement et au rôle central
qui joue dans la mondialisation des
échanges donc sans plus tarder je vais
ouvrir le débat et la première question
du côté de la commission des affaires
économiques et celle de Jean-Claude
Tissot
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général en effet
comme vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente
j'ai cru monsieur le Président Directeur
Général vous aviez pris mes questions
avant votre intervention parce qu'en
fait vous avez répondu déjà à pas mal de
mes questions mais quand même malgré
tout permettez-moi d'avoir vous me
rassurer
bien mis dans une pochette non blague à
part
j'ai quand même quelques questions plus
précises vous avez abordé ces thèmes
mais la fameuse taxation automnage qui
faisait très très favorable sur le plan
fiscal
j'ai pas compris de quelle manière vous
pourriez vous vous imaginez pouvoir
participer aux investissements de la
transition écologique
et puis ensuite pour revenir sur le
sujet de l'énergie vous avez opté et
vous le l'avez dit il y a quelques
années pour une flotte de navire pour
fonctionner au biométhane et ou au gaz
naturel liquéfier ce qui a
progressivement vous l'avez dit aussi
remplacer le fioul lourd et ses
conséquences sur notre environnement et
donc après ces quelques années de
transition êtes-vous en mesure alors
vous l'avez dit mais j'ai pas bien
compris de quelle manière finalement ça
allait impliqué au développement
êtes-vous en mesure aujourd'hui
d'établir un bilan chiffré de cette
évolution que ce soit sur l'impact
environnemental ou en termes
d'efficacité pour les navires
j'ai également et vous l'avez abordé
aussi vu que vous aviez récemment noué
un partenariat stratégique avec Air
France KLM dans le domaine du fret
aérien est-ce que ces éléments de
transition énergétique font partie de
l'accord et si oui dans quelle mesure je
vous remercie
voilà monsieur le Président Directeur
Général vous pouvez répondre à
Jean-Claude Tissot bien sûr
concernant le partenariat avec Air
France KLM je vous citer dans mon propos
que nous avons commandé de nouveau
avions ces avions respecteront les
normes les normes environnementales et
notamment les abus à 350 et Air France
KLM a fait de même donc un ou deux nous
opérons des navires qui nous aideront à
réduire nos émissions de CO2 maintenant
par rapport à la question sur le
transport maritime et ce que nous
faisons par rapport à la décarbonation
du secteur ce que j'ai dit aussi c'est
que je me suis engagé à ce qu'en 2050
nous soyons nets zéro vous me direz nous
sommes en 2022 en 2050 on a le temps
oui et non on a le temps mais de l'autre
côté quand on voit ce qui se passe en ce
moment en France avec les incendies
ailleurs dans le monde et aurgence à
agir c'est pour ça que le groupe CMA CGM
a décidé depuis maintenant plusieurs
années d'investir dans une flotte de
navire au gaz naturel liquéfié donc le
gaz naturel du kéfié nous permet de
réduire nos émissions de CO2 de 20%.
c'est une énergie de transition 20%
c'est pas grand chose surtout si on veut
être à 100% de démission d'être neutre
en carbone en 2050 donc ce qu'il faut
qu'on continue à réfléchir à des
nouvelles énergies et d'où le
partenariat que nous avons noué avec la
société engie qui nous permet ensemble
lors d'une sorte de John vancher de
sélectionner un site en France et à
partir de ce site commencer à développer
du dieu méthane le biométhane nous
permettra de réduire nos émissions de
CO2 de l'ordre de 80%. la difficulté
qu'on a c'est qu'on trouve pas
facilement ce type de produit et donc on
a avec la meilleure volonté du monde
avec les moyens qui sont importants du
groupe CMA-CGM qu'on met en place
communautaire ça veut dire qu'elle
s'applique à toutes les entreprises du
transport maritime européenne et cette
taxe autonage a été mis en place en 2003
pour donner un avantage aux compagnies
européennes face à la concurrence
asiatique
cette taxe automnale est bénéfique pour
nous parce qu'elle nous permet de nous
développer et comme je vous ai expliqué
dans mon propos de réinvestir énormément
de notre profit dans l'entreprise et
donc de développer l'activité commander
des bateaux et acheter des entreprises
dans le domaine de la logistique un
changement par rapport à cette taxe
automnage c'est de donner une prime à
nos concurrents asiatiques est-ce que
c'est ce qu'on veut aujourd'hui je vous
ai dit que le groupe CMA-CGM était un le
numéro 3 mondial est-ce qu'on veut
régresser pour une histoire de taxe
j'ai expliqué dans mon propos toutes les
mesures que le groupe CMA CGM a mis en
place pour faire face à la problématique
du pouvoir d'achat des Français
réduction des tarifs de fret à
destination des Outre-mer réduction des
tarifs de fret à destination de la
métropole et des petites et moyennes
entreprises en leur donnant de la
capacité à bord de nos bateaux à leur
donner des tarifs compétitifs et de les
encourager à signer des accords sur
plusieurs années pour nous permettre
aussi de les satisfaire donc je verrai
plutôt
des actions vis-à des actions
commerciales vis-à-vis de nos clients
que qu'une réflexion qui pourrait avoir
des effets dramatiques sur notre secteur
merci monsieur le Président Directeur
Général sur vos propos liminaires et
puis merci également
à vous à votre groupe pour l'engagement
que vous avez vous prenez sur une
neutralité carbone en 2050 merci je vais
donner la parole à Didier
merci monsieur le Président je suis le
président très heureux de vous
accueillir avec mes collègues ce matin
moi je voudrais m'exprimer en tant que
président du groupe d'études mais
reditoral nous avons eu l'occasion
depuis quelques années
8 ans précisément au travers de
différents textes je pense notamment
économie bleue loi le roi également au
travers du texte loi d'orientation des
mobilités de traiter la question
maritime et plus récemment une
proposition de loi dont j'étais le
rapporteur de tirer du rapport de Michel
laspar mais qui malheureusement n'a pas
n'a pas été transmise aurait été
transmises mais qui n'a pas été reprise
hélas
moi je voudrais vous interroger sur
trois besoin très rapidement le premier
point concerne l'attractivité et la
compétitivité de nos ports vous avez
fait référence au rapport de notre
ancien collègue Michel vaspar qui
soulignait les résultats insuffisants
des ports français en comparaison de
leur concurrents européens et nous avons
cité vous avez cité envers ses Rotterdam
tout à l'heure on regarde des nombreux
atouts maritimes de la France c'est une
déception en 2020 40 % des conteneurs à
destination de la France transitée par
des ports étrangers
identifiez-vous des pistes pour
améliorer le trafic portuaire dans notre
pays et pour réorienter des flux vers
nos ports
plus précisément j'aimerais savoir quel
regard vous portez sur la stratégie
nationale portuaire présentée par le
gouvernement 2021 et quelle mesure nous
devrions selon vous mettre en oeuvre
pour conquérir davantage de flux
européens le rapport de Michel
proposait des solutions deuxièmement sur
le plan de la logistique ce toujours
rapport de Michel vapard identifier
l'insuffisance des capacités de stockage
des ports maritimes français et la
sous-utilisation des modes massifiés
comme des facteurs de restriction de
leur état land dans les ports français
dans lesquels vous possédez des
terminaux quelle stratégie mettez-vous
en oeuvre pour développer l'offre
logistique et le report modal on a eu
l'occasion de visiter Marseille et Le
Havre entre autres enfin je souhaite
également aborder le sujet des nouvelles
routes de la soie développée par la
Chine entre l'Asie l'Europe mais aussi
l'Afrique orientale par voie terrestre
et maritime
votre groupe a une longue histoire vous
l'avez rappelé de coopération avec la
Chine qu'elle regarde portez-vous sur la
stratégie chinoise et selon vous
évidemment quelle stratégie de la France
devrait être à l'adopter face au
développement des prises de
participation des groupes chinois dans
les ports européens en Grèce en Italie
etc
voilà les trois questions que je
souhaitais vous poser et puis je
voudrais simplement conclusion dire que
nous avons beaucoup de chance en France
avoir un groupe qui non seulement à une
stratégie mais une philosophie et une
éthique donc merci de battre pavillon
français
[Applaudissements]
merci pour ces trois sujets
moi je suis personnellement convaincu
que les ports français peuvent rattraper
leur retard
la situation qu'on vit actuellement dans
le monde au niveau des congestions
portuaires il faut pas les regarder
actuellement parce que c'est tellement
une situation unique mais de manière
générale moi à nouveau je suis convaincu
que les ports français peuvent rattraper
leur retard et on a quelques pistes de
réflexion la première piste est
développée l'intermodalité la deuxième
c'est de développer des zones
logistiques d'excellence et puis
également installer des zones de soudage
de biocarburant pour vous donner un
exemple nous nous avons un de nos
services maritimes au départ de Chine à
destination de la Méditerranée sous ta
fosse où nous avons mis en place un
partenariat avec le groupe Total où nous
opérons le soudage directement à fosse
donc vous rond pour essayer de réfléchir
à ce que cela se fasse ailleurs dans
d'autres ports français au niveau de des
Outre-mer ce qu'il faudrait qu'on fasse
ces moderniser
les les infrastructures peut-être en
essayant d'augmenter
les tirant d'eau Rosset le niveau de
prestation de service pour les escales
de nos navires et Associés les acteurs
privés dans le conseil de surveillance
des ports d'outre-mer ça c'est quelques
pistes sur lequel nous on est à la
disposition pour pouvoir les les faire
avancer ensuite concernant
dans les ports où nous sommes
actionnaires
nous essayons de développer des zones de
logistique parce que de plus en plus on
remarque que nos clients nous demandent
non seulement de pouvoir acheminer leur
marchandises d'un port à au port B mais
de pouvoir aussi leur proposer des
solutions de stockage on est on pourrait
être en mesure de le faire dans
l'enceinte portuaire et c'est ce qu'on
fait dans certains endroits du monde
donc ça on souhaiterait l'encourager et
essayer de le mettre en place
la question de la Route de la Soie
ce qu'on voit dans notre secteur c'est
que les volumes au départ de Chine
on continue à se développer
à destination de l'Europe à destination
des États-Unis et d'ailleurs dans le
monde
ce qu'on voit également c'est une
augmentation des trafics régionaux parce
que certains clients ne veulent plus
être prisonniers d'une chaîne logistique
qui a été charité durant cette période
du covid donc on voit beaucoup de
clients qui vont acheter en Turquie au
lieu d'acheter en Chine qui vont acheter
en Tunisie et dans les autres pays du
Maghreb donc la Chine se développe donc
les clients continuent à acheter leurs
produits en Chine mais par contre pour
tout ce qui viendra en plus on voit des
trafics régionaux se développer
fortement dans des pays comme je vous ai
cité la Turquie on parle beaucoup de
l'Inde également on a des services
maritimes qui se développent fortement
au départ d'Inde vers la France parce
que l'Inde devient un pays qui se
développe fortement et que dans certains
cas certains pays ne veulent plus être
tributaires d'un seul endroit pour
s'approvisionner et notamment la Chine
donc la Chine continuera à se développer
mais on voit aussi une augmentation des
trafic régionaux et trafic régionaux je
prends en compte la Turquie
l'Inde pour donner quelques exemples et
évidemment l'Asie du Sud-Est l'Asie du
Sud-Est pour notamment les clients
américains
pardon
l'Asie du Sud-Est se développe beaucoup
Vietnam Thaïlande Indonésie sont des
endroits où beaucoup de clients sont en
train d'aller acheter leur marchandises
en disant on ne veut pas être tributaire
de la manière dont les Chinois gèrent la
crise du covid il faut qu'on aille
trouver un plan B et le plan B est aussi
en Asie du Sud-Est donc on voit beaucoup
on appelle ça le China plus 1 c'est à
dire on continue à acheter en Chine mais
on essaie de trouver aussi des zones
ailleurs où on peut aller trouver des
centres de production qui ne nous lient
pas nécessairement à la Chine
merci je donne la parole à Bernard buis
merci présidente monsieur le Président
vous l'avez rappelé depuis le début de
la CMA CGM vous travaillez étroitement
avec des containers ces boîtes
métalliques conçues pour le transport de
marchandises uniformisé autour d'un
volume de 20 pieds soit 6 mètres si la
constitution de ses conteneurs faite
d'acier léger et favorable à
l'environnement la perte de conteneur en
mer prend de plus en plus d'ampleur avec
le massification des flux maritimes
comment envisagez-vous de faire face à
la régulation de ses pertes face à
certains conteneurs qui sont quelquefois
trois chargés et mal arrimés
vous avez répondu vous-même à la
question
donc aujourd'hui le pourcentage de
navire
qui sont perdus en mer et extrêmement
faible malgré les dizaines de millions
de conteneurs que l'industrie du
transport maritime transporte à bord de
ses bateaux les difficultés qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est dans les ports de
chargement on a des mauvaises
manipulations on a du matériel de
saisissage qui est peut-être obsolète
qu'il faudrait remplacer rapidement et
ça c'est des sujets sur lesquels on
travaille beaucoup parce que on ne peut
pas prôner la neutralité carbone et
avoir un programme environnemental fort
si à côté de ça on a des containers qui
sont perdus en mer ça c'est pas possible
ce n'est pas acceptable donc on nous
fait tous qu'on peut pour remplacer ce
matériel de saisissage de faire en sorte
qu'on donne des instructions très
claires dans les ports de chargement
pour éviter que quand il y a une mère
qui est trop forte parce qu'en général
ça se passe quand la mer est très forte
on a une rangée de containers qui peut
malheureusement passer à l'eau mais
j'insiste c'est très rare le pourcentage
est très faible mais quand ça arrive à
nous de prendre nos responsabilités et
de faire en sorte qu'on règle la
question et notamment dans les portes de
chargement
merci je vais donner la parole à
Philippe Tabaro
madame la Présidente
merci de me passer la parole alors je
vais faire une petite une petite minute
de pub je sais que les collègues adorent
ça je faisais lui d'une grande région
maritime comme vous le savez
provençale-côte d'Azur première région
pour le yachting première destination
française pour la croisière et le
nautisme première base navale de défense
française à Toulon mais chers collègues
mais également la base d'un acteur
portuaire de référence mondial un
fleuron de l'économie française dont
j'ai pu mesurer lors de mes fonctions
régionales l'attachement viscéral à la
cité
marseillaise de votre entreprise
familiale CMA-CGM alors je ne parlerai
pas ici du rachat par exemple du titre
La Provence ni de la coopération avortée
avec le précédent ministre des
Transports ni d'attaxation des profits
qui pour nous n'est pas un gros mot ou
de la taxe automnale vous avez déjà
aborder ce sujet sujet sur lesquels mes
collègues des affaires économiques et de
ma commission vous interrogeront
probablement dans un instant moi je vous
interrogerai très rapidement sur quatre
points qui sont du ressort de notre
commission le verdissement de la flotte
maritime vous en avez dit un mot
l'accessibilité des grands axes la
sécurité des ports en France et votre
stratégie de développement logistique
concernant le verdissement de la flotte
on le sait en 2018 le secteur maritime
était responsable de 13,5% des émissions
de l'Union européenne malgré une volonté
de votre entreprise vous l'avez rappelé
du secteur à s'engager vers la
décarbonation estime que les émissions
de CO2 liées au transport maritime
international vont progresser de 18%
d'ici 2030 et de 39% d'ici 2050 par
temps de ce constat des réformes ont été
entreprises notamment au travers de
l'OMI qui fixe un objectif de neutralité
carbone d'ici et que vous avez récupéré
à votre compte également et c'est très
bien ou encore la Commission européenne
qui a annonçait l'intégration du
transport maritime au marché carbone
européen dès 2023-25 qu'elle regarde
portez-vous sur cette réforme et ne
craignez-vous pas de potentiels effets
d'évitement des ports européens sur les
activités de transbordement cette
question de la compétitivité de nos
ports m'amène à vous demander votre avis
sur les leviers publics pour favoriser
la décarbonation aujourd'hui dans le cas
de la loi de finances 22 les conditions
d'éligibilité au sur amortissement vert
ont été élargies et j'ai avec un certain
nombre de collègues portaient des
amendements destinés à porter à 105% le
taux déduction fiscale applicable à
l'acquisition d'équipement velik
identifiez-vous d'autres leviers publics
pour des carbonner nos transports
maritimes ensuite concernant
l'accessibilité des grands axes
pouvez-vous confirmer qu'à court terme
ces derniers ne devraient pas être de
verser cependant on voit qu'à moyen
terme compte tenu de la baisse des
besoins en pétrole brûlent au profit des
produits raffinés de l'augmentation des
besoins gaz naturel l'importance
stratégique de certaines routes
pourraient évoluer j'aimerais connaître
votre positionnement clair stratégique
et vitale sur ces questions même si vous
nous avez dit que c'était pas le cœur de
des marchandises que vous que vous
transportez enfin sur ce sujet des roues
de maritimes qu'on vient de souligner
votre décision vous en avez dit un mot
qui
interdit d'emprunter les vous êtes
interdits d'emprunter les routes du nord
pour favoriser la protection des échos
système fragile nous ne pouvons que
saluer cette décision mais la France
s'est-elle exprime mais pour inviter
d'autres armateurs étrangers à suivre
votre exemple
concernant la sécurité des ports
j'aimerais dire un mot nous venons avec
mes excellents collègues Pascal martin
et martine filleul de un rapport
d'études sur les transports de nitrates
d'ammonium à la suite de l'accident de
Beyrouth une ville qui est chère à votre
cœur et puis une circulaire de la
première ministre sur la sûreté maritime
et portuaire vient de tomber le 18
juillet dernier c'est-à-dire avant-hier
en fin dernière question je souhaite et
vous l'avez rappelé essayez de
comprendre
ce qui a motivé vos investissements à la
fois l'acquisition du terminal à Los
Angeles Colis Privé capital d'Air France
pouvez-vous nous expliquer la logique de
ces investissements dans votre chaîne de
développement logistique et une petite
question je sais pas si vous allez nous
répondre sur ce sujet mes parents du
capital d'Air France est-ce que vous
avez été vous démarcher Air France
est-ce que Air France vous a démarché ou
est-ce que l'État
français vous a demandé de démarcher Air
France
merci chers collègues pour ces judicieux
questions et pour cette intermède
publicitaire merci
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
vous m'avez posé tellement de questions
je vais essayer de me rappeler des
questions que m'avait posé
au niveau de la sécurité dans les ports
c'est un sujet majeur et les difficultés
que nous avons c'est on fait face à des
trafics dans les ports qui deviennent
problématiques et notamment des trafics
de de drogue donc aujourd'hui c'est un
sujet majeur pour l'industrie du
transport maritime et donc en
partenariat avec les douanes en France
et ailleurs dans le monde on essaie de
faire très attention à ces
problématiques là et ensuite dans les
terminaux que nous opérons nous avons
une politique
qsse
qui est un terme un peu barbare mais qui
veut dire que on fait de notre mieux
pour continuer à s'assurer que
nos équipages nos navires sont sécurisés
durant leur passage dans les différents
terminaux que nous opérons ou ceux où
nous sommes uniquement
clients sur le verdissement de la flotte
je pense que ce qui est important il n'y
a pas de solution miracle aujourd'hui à
la décarbonation il faut il faut du
temps il faut beaucoup d'investissement
et on a on en fait beaucoup et tout ce
qu'on peut essayer de faire que ça soit
dans le transport maritime et maintenant
dans l'aérien il faut qu'on le fasse
parce que le sujet est important il est
important à mes yeux il mobilise les
collaborateurs de CMA CGM donc c'était
un sujet certainement majeurs au niveau
de la logistique je vous ai expliqué la
stratégie du groupe CMA-CGM c'est
transport maritime qui est notre cœur de
métier mais maintenant la logistique
pourquoi la logistique beaucoup de nos
clients qui utilisent nos navires pour
acheminer leur marchandises d'un port a
à un port B nous demande également des
solutions logistiques que ça veut dire
des solutions logistiques ça veut dire
des solutions d'entreposage ça veut dire
du dernier kilomètre ça veut dire
également tout ce qui concerne les
formalités douanières et aujourd'hui
avec le pôle logistique qui commence à
jouer un rôle important
au sein du groupe on est en mesure
d'offrir à nos grands comptes que ça
soit des clients comme Decathlon comme
des clients comme Walmart qui est un
grand de la distribution américaine on
est en mesure de leur offrir ces
solutions là
l'activité de ces vases développe ce que
je souhaiterais c'est qu'elle se
développe rapidement
d'où le fait qu'on regarde ce qui se
passe au niveau du marché et si on
trouve qu'il y a des cibles
intéressantes on regarde à acheter
également sur le marché certains de nos
concurrents qui peuvent être
complémentaires à ce que notre société
de logistique fait et en parallèle
développer aussi sous forme de
croissance organique l'activité de de
ces va logistique donc le pôle
logistique se renforce les opérations de
croissance externes qui ont été
réalisées dans la logistique c'est pour
créer un ensemble solide le transport
maritime est un secteur cyclique
ou malheureusement vous pouvez avoir
quelques très bonnes années et quelques
années plus difficiles la logistique est
plus stable vous avez des résultats qui
sont positifs mais qui sont moins
excessifs à la hausse ou à la baisse que
dans le transport maritime et les
investissements qu'on fait dans la
logistique sont moins conséquents que
dans le transport maritime aujourd'hui
pour vous donner un exemple un navire de
très grande taille qu'on opé à nous
c'est à ma cégem coûte 250 millions de
dollars un bateau en général pour faire
Chine Europe Chine il faut environ 13
bateaux donc faites le compte 13 fois
250 millions ça fait beaucoup d'argent
et comme nos clients sont exigeants ils
demandent à ce qui est un départ par
jour au départ de Chine donc il faut
rajouter d'autres d'autres services
supplémentaires donc les investissements
dans la logistique sont moins moins
conséquents et la rentabilité je dirais
est plus stable que dans le shipping
l'aérien pourquoi l'aérien durant la
période de covid certains de nos clients
qui avaient l'habitude de transporter
leur marchandises dans la soute des
avions passagers et comme les avions
passagers a été cloués au sol à cause de
la crise sanitaire se sont retrouvés
avec leurs produits sans mode de
transport ils nous ont approchés en
disant c'est un massage est-ce que vous
faites de l'aérien est-ce qu'il y a un
moyen de nous aider et je me suis dit le
maire la meilleure réponse à leurs
problématique c'est d'essayer de trouver
des avions cargo qu'on puisse mettre à
leur disposition pour acheminer leur
marchandises et donc on a commencé par
quatre avions et d'ici 2025 on en aura
nous CMA CGM 12
pour être plus fort
il vaut mieux être à deux
et donc on a cherché sur le marché un
partenaire avec qui on pourrait
s'associer pour pouvoir offrir un réseau
à nos clients plus important et à
service plus fiable et on a trouvé que
Air France KLM qui est un très beau
groupe français nous apporte cette ces
solutions là donc on a mis un an à nous
mettre d'accord donc ce qui avait des
discussions animées mais intéressantes
et aujourd'hui ce partenariat qui est
une sous forme d'une jeune vincher
commercial nous donne la possibilité de
devenir numéro 1 européen numéro 4
mondial avec une flotte au total de 22
avions cargo
pourquoi l'investissement dans Air
France KLM
parce que pour moi l'avenir de notre
entité aérienne est importante et je
souhaite la pérenniser
je la pérennise d'un côté avec le
partenariat dans la joncher mais je veux
pouvoir peser dans la jungle et donc
j'ai souhaité et comme Air France KLM
cherchait des partenaires pour
participer à son augmentation de capital
on est rentré avec 400 millions
d'investissements et 9% et un siège au
bord donc à partir de là je pense que je
suis en mesure de sécuriser mon
investissement dans dans
merci je vais laisser la parole à Fabien
gay dont je suis sûr qu'il fera une
intervention avec peut-être un peu plus
de sobriété que que Philippe tabarrau
bien sûr madame la Présidente sobriété
étant mon surnom sur le président
directeur général non j'ai deux
questions précises c'est d'abord un
plaisir d'avoir un président directeur
général d'une grande entreprise
française je le dis qui développe
beaucoup de choses qui investit vous
avez raison bon d'ailleurs je pense que
on aurait un débat sur l'aménagement du
territoire parce qu'on a une question
écologique pour l'instant la peu ou pas
évoquer mais c'est que quand les
containers arrivent le mieux c'est que
il ne roule pas sur des camions mais ils
sont sur du frais de ferroviaire et on a
par exemple un problème avec un nœud
autour de Lyon donc je pense que là on
aurait un vrai débat pour accompagner et
développer ça mais comme on est au Sénat
on pense qu'il faut qu'on soit précis et
j'ai deux questions vous y êtes venu
vous l'avez dit vous avez une
responsabilité sociale en tant que grand
groupe et je juge pas les questions
humanitaires ou de charité que nous
avait expliqué elles sont très très bien
évidemment mais il faut qu'on donne des
chiffres sur l'inflation par exemple sur
les containers depuis la sortie de la
crise on est passé de 2000 euros à
environ 13000 euros même si vous
expliquez que ça allait se tasser donc
c'est quand même une inflation
conséquente on va le dire comme ça en
deux ans qui s'explique pour plusieurs
raisons pénurie de main d'oeuvre pénurie
d'un certain nombre de choses
augmentation aussi des prix du fioul
mais quand même c'est pas rien de 2000 à
13000 et donc la première question c'est
ce que vous considérez que les 500 euros
demandés par le gouvernement en moins
sont suffisants dans le moment où les
prix explosent pour l'ensemble des
consommateurs à des consommatrices après
vous avez raison si vous faites le geste
qu'on vous demande de 500 euros il faut
être sûr que ça soit répercuté en moins
sur les prix pour les consommateurs et
consommatrices et que ça soit pas une
autre bout de la chaîne qui continue à
faire des marges donc là bon monsieur
Duplomb vous posera la question donc là
est-ce que vous considérez ou pas que
c'est suffisant dans le moment dans
lequel on vit et comment être sûr que ça
soit répercuté et la deuxième question
pardon mais là aussi c'est pas pour un
jugement mais pour qu'on comprenne j'ai
lu un article de nos confrères de la
Croix un très bon journal la semaine
dernière et vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure
très bon journal La Croix très très bon
journal sur la question de l'imposition
là aussi pas de jugement mais vous avez
parlé dans votre propos introductif nous
payons des impôts et nous avons la taxe
sur le tournage l'an dernier si le
chiffre sont bons mais s'ils sont pas
bons vous me le dites 16 milliards
bénéfices là aussi vous l'avez expliqué
il y a des moments où ça ça baisse qui
est vrai des moments d'explosion on
vient d'en parler avec le prix des
containers qui a explosé c'est
normalement c'est normal que les
bénéfices explosent
2% d'impôts payés 370 millions d'euros
c'est des chiffres qui sont aussi
présents sur votre site est-ce que vous
considérez dans le moment que nous
sommes que 2% d'impôts sont suffisants
et justement sur cette question la
responsabilité sociale lorsque des
artisans des commerçants paient 30%
d'impôts je le dis évidemment vous allez
me dire oui mais si on si on est taxé
plus que les autres on va perdre de la
compétitivité oui d'accord
est-ce que à ce titre là on doit
permettre que une un très grand groupe
font vous paye 2 % d'impôts c'est à dire
370 millions d'euros sur 16 milliards de
bénéfices l'an dernier là je repose la
question au président directeur général
qui nous a dit qu'il avait une
responsabilité sociale je pense que là
on a une question au moment où et j'en
finis par là comme ça j'aurais été un
peu plus sobre mais pas tout à fait que
mon autre collègue où on va avoir un
débat sur le pouvoir d'achat une
question autour de la taxe des super
profits des méga profits qui va venir
sur la table après on aura le débat
entre nous mais je vous repose cette
question voilà je vous remercie en tout
cas monsieur le Président Directeur
Général
quelqu'un qui est censé être sobre
je comprends les deux questions je
comprends ces deux questions elles sont
importantes je commence par les taux de
fret
j'ai essayé d'expliquer dans ma
présentation que nous vivons dans une
période exceptionnelle ou la demande
a été exceptionnel on n'a jamais connu
une telle demande
liée à la problématique du covid on ne
s'attendait pas à ce que les
consommateurs consomment autant
et donc il y a la politique de l'offre
et de la demande et à partir de là il y
a un marché et le marché a explosé à la
hausse
j'entends mes clients ou les clients de
manière générale qui trouvent que c'est
trop
on est venu avec une série de mesures
pour essayer d'aider
on a mis en place le gel des tarifs de
fret que ça soit pour la métropole
ou pour les outre-mer on a décidé de
j'ai proposé à à Bercy de réduire de 500
euros les tarifs de fret nous avons
également nous sommes également venus en
aide au PME en leur donnant accès à de
la capacité en leur donnant des tarifs
réduits aujourd'hui je suis le seul ou
la seule compagnie maritime à faire ce
que je fais mais concurrents personne
n'a bougé donc j'entends le fait de dire
les tarifs sont très élevés mais il faut
que vous regardiez ce que font mes
concurrents pour l'instant ils n'ont pas
bougé alors peut-être parce qu'ils sont
pas français mais moi en tant que
Français j'ai pris des mesures vous me
direz c'est pas assez j'ai fait des
propositions au gouvernement de décider
ce qu'il veut faire moi je considère que
mon devoir et de continuer à investir à
créer de l'emploi à rester rentable
quand mais t'arrive de fret était à 350
dollars vous étiez où
et qu'il a fallu un moment donné se
demander si on allait passer
la semaine ou pas personne n'est venu
nous parler personne n'est venu nous
dire quoi que ce soit on s'est
débrouillé donc c'est là où je dis à un
moment donné j'entends la remarque et on
fait tout ce qu'on peut s'il faut faire
plus à l'état de me dire moi j'ai fait
des propositions j'ai mis en place un
programme et aujourd'hui
l'impact du tarif de Fred si vous prenez
par exemple des baskets qui viennent de
Chine admettons un conteneur de 20 pieds
qui transportent quelque chose comme
8000 basket le prix d'une basket et de
l'ordre de 50 euros
l'impact du tarif de fret et pour un
tarif de fret à 8000 dollars le 40 pieds
c'est 1 € sur une paire de basket c'est
beaucoup peut-être mais c'est peut-être
pas beaucoup non plus donc je dis il
faut aussi relativiser ce que ça veut
dire ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que
les tarifs qu'on a connu il y a quelques
années ne sont pas le reflet de la
réalité
ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui aussi il
faut qu'il y ait un moment donné à juste
équilibre et le juste et l'équilibre
c'est le marché qui va le décider nous
on est prêt à prendre des actions on est
prêt à aider on est prêt à faire
beaucoup de choses
et vous avez vu dans ce que j'ai dit
depuis maintenant 1h30 on a mis en place
un programme mais pas uniquement de la
charité non mais de l'argent sur la
table et on aide les consommateurs en
faisant ce qu'il faut moi ce que je
voudrais c'est qu'on arrête de regarder
cm à CGM et qu'on aille regarder mes
concurrents et qu'on leur dise CMA fait
beaucoup qu'est-ce que vous faites
surtout les concurrents qui desservent
le marché français maintenant
l'imposition
on est sujet à deux taxes en France nous
sommes assez GM la taxe automnage qui
concerne le transport maritime et l'ISF
qui est liesse qui lui est un une taxe
qui concerne le l'activité portuaire de
CMA-CGM et l'activité logistique donc la
taxe automatique c'est uniquement cela
division maritime alors qu'on paye 25%
sur tout ce qui concerne le portuaire et
et la logistique si un changement de
taxe devait pour la partie maritime
devait être mis en place je ne veux pas
à moi groupe CMA CGM groupe français
fleurons du transport maritime en France
me retrouver dans une situation de
désavantage ou mes concurrents
bénéficient de la même taxe que moi à
mes concurrents européens donc on va
dire CMA CGM vous vous allez payer mais
votre concurrent danois votre
concurrence Suisse lui il va il va être
paiera pas c'est pas honnête vis-à-vis
de nous vous pensez pas
un moment donné je veux bien qu'on qu'on
arrive avec des recommandations mais il
faut qu'elle soit réaliste ces
recommandations et moi je ne veux pas
être le seul à payer et on fait
énormément de choses aujourd'hui je suis
le seul à les faire je dois continuer à
faire plus parce qu'il faut continuer à
aider au pouvoir d'achat mais je peux
pas être le seul
merci c'est un vrai sujet
la parole est un article
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général vous avez
montré depuis le début de votre propos
que le transport maritime s'inscrivait
dans une chaîne logistique globale pour
ma part donc je voulais vous interroger
sur un point précis de cette chaîne
logistique qui concerne le poste
acheminement sur l'articulation entre le
transport maritime et les modes de
transport terrestre et également le
transport fluvial vous le savez la
France avec la contribution déterminée
du Sénat c'est fixé des objectifs
ambitieux en matière de frais de
fluviale notamment dans le contrat
d'objectifs et de performance qui lie
l'État avec son opérateur VNF votre
décision rendue publique début mars
d'effacement d'internalisation du surco
engendré par la manutention fluviale est
un signe fort de votre intérêt pour le
développement de ce mode sur et vertueux
sur le plan environnemental ce gain de
compétitivité a été saluée par
l'ensemble de la profession et constitue
un pas tout à fait important pour autant
et malgré une infrastructure sur
capacitaire en France le fret fluvial
progresse insuffisamment avez-vous
identifiez d'autres freins à lever pour
que le trafic national soit comparable à
ce observer chez nos voisins du nord
quel est votre vision de l'articulation
fluvio maritime notamment sur les axes
de la scène et du Rhône je vous remercie
merci pour la question peut-être je
commencerai par dire un mot sur le frais
de ferroviaire
et peut-être pour répondre à la
précédente question nous sommes très en
faveur au développement du frais de
ferroviaire et d'ailleurs on a certaines
marchandises qui viennent par train de
Chine jusqu'au nord de l'Europe et c'est
un secteur qui se développe fortement
donc par rapport à ça il y a on peut
certainement faire mieux au niveau frais
de ferroviaire mais en tout cas il y a
des trains qui relient l'Allemagne au
départ de Shanghai et donc ça il faut
continuer à le développer maintenant
concernant le fluvial bien sûr qu'il
faut développer le fluvial mais la
concurrence de la route est-elle qu'il
est difficile aujourd'hui avec le peu
peu de fréquences pour faire du fausse
lion par voie fluviale on ne passera pas
donc idéalement c'est d'améliorer la
fréquence des multiples barges qui
desservent cette cette partie et à
partir de là nous on est très enclin à
dérouter certaines marchandises de
d'aller davantage vers le fluvial mais
aujourd'hui la fréquence est tellement
faible qu'on aura du mal à rester
compétitif donc oui il faut développer
le fluvial oui nous sommes prêts à
participer mais par contre il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver un produit qui soit
compétitif
en temps et en argent
merci la parole est à Daniel salmon
merci madame le Président merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Président
Directeur Général merci pour votre
exposé
vous nous avez exprimé votre pleine
conscience des problématiques de
réchauffement climatique
vous nous avez exposé un certain nombre
d'actions sur GNL et puis biométhane
vous nous avez pas parlé de la
propulsion par voile je ne sais pas où
vous en êtes sur vos réflexions
puisqu'il y a des voiles souples et
voiles rigides il y a des différents
moyens éoliens donc pour propulser les
bateaux qui peuvent amener selon ce que
j'ai lu de 10 à 40% d'économies en
émission de gaz à effet de serre
également la réduction de la vitesse est
un des éléments qui peut être envisagé
un à deux nœuds de moins permet
également de baisser de 10 excusez-moi
de 10 à 20% les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre donc deux éléments qui me
semblent importants sur lesquels vous
allez pouvoir nous répondre et puis et
bien on parle aujourd'hui beaucoup de
relocalisation de l'économie
quels sont pour vous les perspectives
sur le trafic maritime international
s'il y a une vraie relocalisation de
l'économie dans les années à venir merci
concernant le premier sujet du velik
aujourd'hui la plupart des navires que
nous opérons sont de navires de très
grande taille
si on avait à changer le mode de
propulsion en utilisant pour faire une
traversée Chine Europe la voile je suis
pas sûr à temps qu'on répondra à la
question par contre ce que je pense
c'est une réflexion sur l'assistance
velique sur certains tronçons d'une
rotation est intéressante à regarder la
difficulté aussi du velik c'est qu'ils
vont prendre beaucoup d'espace à bord de
nos avions de nos bateaux
porte-conteneurs donc il y a une
réflexion on est ouvert à la discussion
ça peut être qu'une assistance védique à
nouveau sur un tronçon bien spécifique
concernant la réduction de la vitesse à
partir de janvier 2023 il y a de
nouvelles normes environnementales qui
se mettent en place donc les compagnies
maritimes vont devoir opérer des navires
dits verts et donc le groupe CMA CGM si
emploi ces nouvelles réglementations
vont nous obliger à aussi réduire la
vitesse donc ça répond en partie à votre
à votre problématique donc janvier 2023
il faut qu'on respecte les nouvelles
règles environnementales et si on n'est
pas en mesure de faire ça on devra radio
à la vitesse donc de toute façon c'est
un sujet que l'Europe et les Nations
Unies ont pris à bras le corps et nous
aurons à partir de l'année prochaine de
nouvelles normes qui nous obligeront à
respecter certains critères doux et
aidons la réduction de la vitesse
maintenant la troisième question c'est
la relocalisation comme je disais
il y a certains produits que nous allons
continuer à acheter en Asie
on aime bien changer de téléviseur
régulièrement et donc il faut que le
téléviseur ne coûte pas cher le seul
endroit où il est fabriqué à moindre
coût c'est en Asie et je ne vois pas une
relocalisation en Europe de ce type de
produit par contre il y a certaines
marchandises
qui elles peuvent être produites
ailleurs je vous ai pris l'exemple de la
Turquie de la Tunisie pour les textiles
ça oui ça on regarde on voit un
phénomène ou certains centres de
production sont en train de se
rapprocher des centres de consommation
ou le prix n'est pas un critère
important mais par contre tout ce qui
est
technologie et autres ça continuera à
venir d'Asie parce que ça coûte moins
cher pour ne pas dire de Chine mais il y
a certaines commodités qui vont se
relocaliser avec une augmentation des
trafics régionaux mais je ne vois pas un
bouleversement majeur de ce qu'on fait
avec l'Asie
merci la parole est un jeu de Préville
merci monsieur le Président Madame le
présidente monsieur le Président
Directeur Général merci de répondre à
nos questions alors mes questions vont
croiser des questions qui sont des qui
ont déjà été posées mais je vais vous
demander quelques précisions alors
certes au sujet des carburants le GNL ne
pourra être qu'une étape mais moi je
vais vous demander si vous comment vous
regardez notamment des initiatives je ne
sais pas si vous connaissez comme
énergie observer qui est mais en
qui pratique le mix énergétique sur ces
navires enfin sur son navire
expérimental notamment en croisant
l'éolien les panneaux photovoltaïques la
voile et quel avenir vous voyez à tout
cela et une question aussi est-ce que
l'avenir sera toujours la grande taille
au niveau du transport de marchandises
comment vous vous projeter surtout que
comment vous voyez l'avenir en fait
parce qu'on va mettre en place des
corridors vert ou
peut-être tout dire n'auront plus le
droit de circuler de la même manière et
par rapport à une question auquel vous
avez répondu tout à l'heure sur le
transport plus vertueux quel
investissement vous envisagez de faire
peut-être dans le frais de ferroviaire
et peut-être qu'on serait très heureux
que vous investissiez sur ce sujet là
parce que le frais de ferviaire ne se
développe peut-être pas suffisamment
de manière importante en France et puis
j'en viens un autre sujet mais mes
collègues me voient venir vous avez
répondu tout à l'heure au sujet des
conteneurs qui sont perdus en mer alors
si le trafic augmente beaucoup même si
le pourcentage est faible cela veut dire
qu'il y a de plus en plus quand même de
conteneurs qui sont perdus en mer quelle
est la connaissance que vous avez des
contenus des containers et moi je vais
vous parler de
quelques containers perdus et ça
n'étonnera personne que je parle de la
production de la pollution plastique il
a été par le passé perdu des conteneurs
avec des jouets vous savez des petits
des petits canards comme ça mais l'océan
n'est pas une baignoire et on les a
retrouvés partout sur la planète
plus récemment le xpresser Pearl qui a
brûlé a perdu pas mal de containers qui
contenaient des granulés de plastique
vierge ce qui a impacté je pense que
c'était les plages du Sri Lanka on a
l'impression quand on regardait les
photos qu'il avait neigé et justement
quel regard vous portez sur ces
pollutions qui sont des pollutions qui
ne sont pas neutres qui sont peut-être
pas régulière heureusement qui n'impacte
que des très petits territoires mais le
Sri Lanka est un territoire qui
malheureusement en ce moment vit des
moments difficiles mais très touristique
et l'impact a été très fort et par
rapport à ce qu'on avait mis en place
sur la pollution aux hydrocarbures lors
des marées noires c'est à dire des fonds
internationaux d'indemnisation comment
vous quel regard vous portez sur la
possibilité un jour peut-être de faire
ça et notamment parce que quand il a des
accidents ou des pertes ce serait bien
que les territoires concernés les îles
ou autres pays puisse faire de la
prévention lors de ses pertes et enfin
les containers perdus en mer qui sont
qui restent au fond des océans vont se
détériorer et relarguer tout leur
contenu un jour ou l'autre donc voilà
pour ma dernière question merci en tout
cas
merci à vous je commence par NRJ
observer nous sommes partenaires
d'énergie observer donc nous travaillons
en étroite collaboration avec avec
énergie observer et on continuera à
faire des partenariats de ce type parce
que je pense que ça nous apporte des
enseignements sur comment essayer de
réfléchir ensemble aux énergies de
demain et ça c'est certainement une
manière de le voir concernant la taille
des bateaux
il y a quelques années on avait tendance
à dire on est arrivé à la taille
maximale et puis quelques temps après il
y avait un bateau encore plus grand
aujourd'hui je pense que on est arrivé
techniquement on peut faire plus grand
mais je pense qu'on est arrivé au
maximum et la plupart des commandes
actuelles sont des tailles des commandes
de navire de plus petite taille
aujourd'hui les grands bateaux qui sont
des bateaux de 400 mètres et qui
transportent jusqu'à 23000 conteneurs
c'est les plus gros du marché le groupe
CMA CGM a une flotte de 13 navires de
cette taille là donc je pense qu'on a
atteint la limite c'est des bateaux qui
sont difficiles à manœuvrer pas tous les
ports sont en mesure de les accommoder
et il faut surtout les remplir donc je
pense que on va aller plutôt vers
détails de plus petites et je dirais
qu'on est aux environs entre 10 et 15000
conteneurs ça ce serait pour moi je
pense la norme qu'on va voir de plus en
plus entre 10000 et 15000 conteneurs
la plupart des bateaux qui sortent de
chantier aujourd'hui sont des navires
qui sont les grands bateaux sont des
navires qui sont propulsés au GNL ou au
méthanol donc l'industrie du transport
maritime c'est à massage en tête ont
pris conscience du rôle important qu'on
joue par rapport à la protection de
l'environnement et donc nous moi je me
suis engagé à ce que tous les bateaux
qui sortent de chantier seront au GNL en
attendant qu'on trouve mieux
donc ça ça c'est un engagement qu'on a
pris pour les bateaux de taille 10000 et
plus le fait le fait de ferroviaire
on fait au mieux pour continuer à le à
le pousser à le privilégier mais
aujourd'hui le frais de ferroviaire
coûte plus cher que le fret maritime
donc déjà qu'on se plaint que le fret
maritime coûte cher imaginez-vous le
faire revient donc c'est pour ça que je
dis
on est arrivé à une période de pique au
niveau des tarifs de Fred on voit que
les frais sont en train de baisser et on
a perdu plus de 40%
de par rapport à ce qu'on avait au
niveau des taux de fret il y a quelques
semaines donc la tendance est amorcée à
la baisse et donc peut-être que le frère
vert va continuer à se développer et
agrandir
la perte en mer des conteneurs vous avez
raison de de poser cette question parce
que malheureusement c'est des choses qui
arrivent même si
le nombre de containers qui sont passés
à l'eau et restent extrêmement faible
mais il faut peut-être qu'on arrive à
faire quelque chose avec dans le cadre
d'une mesure de l'industrie du transport
maritime pour essayer de voir qu'est-ce
qu'on fait le jour où ça arrive
parce que le fait de dire j'ai pas vu
c'est pas possible ça
ça c'est ça dépend
ça dépend donc et est-ce qu'on sait ce
qu'il y a dans le container oui oui on
sait ce qu'il y a dans le container on
sait ce qu'il y a dans le container
et on peut pas faire comme si on n'avait
pas vu
donc on a une responsabilité par rapport
à ça
difficile
mais à nouveau le pourcentage est
extrêmement faible
merci je passe la parole à Rémi Cardon
merci madame le Président déjà vous
remercier pour les résultats plutôt
positifs et les investissements qui
aboutissent en tout cas à quelque chose
puisque vous êtes un leader mondial en
la matière déjà dans un premier point
c'était surtout vous remercier pour
cette réussite entrepreneuriale et puis
dans un second temps plutôt vous poser
des questions sur l'impact
environnemental je parle de ce sujet
puisque vous êtes certainement au
courant qu'il y a une une pétition de la
mairie de Marseille qui est sorti de
l'os sans faire de jeux de mots
cette pétition est le fruit d'un
ras-le-bol de nombreux habitants qui
bénéficient d'une Méditerranée polluée
alors je suis pas sénateur des
Bouches-du-Rhône mais je suis sénateur
de la somme mais je voudrais pas leur
proposer unique enfin que la seule
solution soit d'aller se baigner en Baie
de Somme comprenez que je peux pas
expliquer ça des Marseillais en tout cas
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
je vous question est simple êtes-vous
plutôt favorable dans la mesure du
possible d'interdire les escales pour
l'énergie les navires les plus polluants
durant les pics de pollution faut-il
pour aller plus loin dans la démarche
faut-il justement
construire une politique de
labellisation pour déterminer quelles
sont les navires pollants et valoriser
ceux qui font des efforts
et puis un autre sujet qui est qui
complète un peu mon raisonnement c'est
que aujourd'hui on sait il y a des
communes qui sont soumises à
l'instauration des des zones à faible
émission pour leur trafic routier mais
malheureusement
ces villas qui sont parfois ont un
trafic routier et en plus ce sont des
villes portuaires
enfin en tout cas certaines remontées en
tout cas de certains mères se posent des
questions sur l'insuffisance pour le
notamment pour le cas de Marseille une
ville que vous connaissez très très bien
et vous pouvez comprendre que pour des
habitants
on sait qu'on fait des efforts sur le
trafic routier et en même temps
quels sont les vecteurs ou les les
moyens à mettre en oeuvre pour limiter
en tout cas le trafic maritime vous avez
aussi conscience je pense que le
l'Organisation maritime internationale
va examiner à l'échelle de toute la
Méditerranée une réglementation pour
limiter les émissions de soufre des
bateaux je suppose que vous êtes sur le
sujet et donc ma question aussi c'est
effectivement
au moment où les épisodes de canicule
deviennent de plus en plus fréquents
comme cette semaine induisant d'ailleurs
des concentrations de d'ozone et de
polluants atmosphérique bien au-delà des
seuils acceptables je pense qu'il est
temps d'agir positivement c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous demande une
peut-être une feuille de route plus
précise dans la matière surtout sur une
zone que vous connaissez bien comme
comme Marseille vous comprenez je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure qu'on peut pas
uniquement proposer aux Marseillais
d'aller se baigner en Baie de Somme
je peux répondre pour ce qui concerne le
transport maritime de conteneur parce
que dans transport maritime il y a aussi
la croisière et je m'exprimerai pas cela
croisière ce que je dirais sur le
transport maritime de conteneur la
flotte de CMA CGM de manière générale et
relativement moderne et répond aux
normes qui nous sont imposées et comme
je le disais également tout à l'heure à
partir de janvier 2023 il va avoir des
normes qui sont imposées par l'Europe et
par les institutions internationales qui
sont assez fortes sur la pollution de
notre industrie donc moi je on fera ce
qu'il faut pour continuer à travailler
sur la pollution et je suis prêt à
m'engager à faire ce qu'il faut ça c'est
certain
dans mon secteur ça c'est certain donc
utiliser ou opérer des navires ils sont
qui polluent non ça c'est pas possible
ça c'est pas possible dans à nous de
faire ce qu'il faut pour les rendre
opérables et ça je suis prêt à m'engager
merci je vais donner la parole à Bruno
Bella
merci monsieur le Président merci Madame
indice Présidente je suis le président
ça d'abord un grand merci pour votre
présentation d'ouverture qui m'a
impressionné et dans sa présentation
évidemment dans son contenu je voudrais
y avoir deux questions très courtes
promis une pour revenir sur celle de
l'excellent Philippe Tabaro comme il dit
je sais pas si vous avez bien répondu
bienvenue pas
qualitativement mais dans la réponse
complète sur ces questions sur Air
France et je me permets de vouloir poser
puis je voulais avoir votre avis sur Air
France la deuxième partie de la question
c'est ça voilà ou alors j'ai eu un
moment d'absence de mes je peux vous
assurer que je vous écoute bien depuis
10h ce matin votre avis sur Air France
en plus avec nous sommes dans une
période où l'avion bashing est tellement
facile et Air France est pourtant une
très belle compagnie aussi j'en suis
convaincu donc votre vision sur
l'aviation et sur cette compagnie phare
pour nous Air France et puis deuxième
question qui n'a rien à voir mais qui
relève de l'aménagement du territoire
qui nous est cher dans cette maison
votre avis sur l'état des ports en
France
concernant
l'investissement dans Air France
moi pour moi la marque Air France KLM
est une marque magique je trouve c'est
une super compagnie qui a ses
difficultés mais qui a aussi un
potentiel très fort et si on ayant
investi au capital d'Air France je peux
contribuer à continuer à faire que Air
France se développe et améliore certains
de ses problèmes je serai présent
l'autre point de de la question
comme j'ai pu le dire dans mon propos on
est un groupe qui est très attaché à la
France et on a un groupe patriote
et donc ce qui fait que
je pense que notre groupe joue un rôle
important à ce niveau-là on a fait
l'opération Air France KLM parce qu'elle
faisait sens
au niveau de du
partenariat avec Air France puisqu'on
est ensemble une flotte d'avion et si
elle peut contribuer à continuer à
développer et à renforcer la France je
réponds présent
donc là j'ai fait mieux que la
précédente réponse en vous disant que
l'esprit patriotique est un sujet qui
est important pour moi et voilà et donc
ce qui fait que j'ai les moyens de faire
ce que je fais donc je continuerai à le
faire
sur l'état des ports je trouve que les
ports français qu'ils soient en
métropole ou en outre-mer son des ports
qui fonctionnent bien il faut continuer
à les développer parce qu'on a réalisé
qu'en période de covid il y avait
quelques difficultés qu'il faut essayer
de régler mais de manière générale si je
compare les portes français au port
européen les ports français fonctionnent
et il y a pas de sujet mais il faut
évidemment vu les quantités de volume
concrètes il faut faire en sorte
d'agrandir quand cela est possible de
mettre des zones de stockage des zones
logistiques dans les enceintes
portuaires Consolat est possible mais on
est sur sur la bonne tendance
ça sert à rien de critiquer quand ça va
mais il faut faire mieux sûrement
merci Patricia chainger oui merci merci
monsieur le Président Directeur moi je
vais vous poser la question sur les
produits que vous transportez est-ce que
vous avez un grand marché sur les
produits pharmaceutiques puisque c'est
le gros sujet aussi on a vu pendant le
covid qui avait des ruptures de
d'approvisionnement des produits de
santé votre marché en Afrique vous nous
avez pas parlé d'Afrique mais beaucoup
d'Asie est-ce que vous avez un marché
qui est important sur le transport et
aussi de bien-être animal vous savez
très bien que aussi je pense que vous
transportez des animaux comment ça se
passe il y a un moment donné il y avait
vraiment des passages horribles dans vus
à la télé sur certains transports de
bétail si vous pouvez nous en dire plus
merci
je vais regarder toutes les questions
possibles et imagibles vous pouvez me
poser mais cela vous avez fait très fort
sur les animaux on transporte des
animaux vivants
dans nos avions et également dans nos
bateaux et
je ça se passe bien on en fait pas tout
le temps mais quand on en fait on le
fait professionnellement
concernant le transport de
produits pharmaceutiques nous en
transportons également dans des
containers réfrigérés
et on a transporté surtout durant la
période de covid
ce type de marchandises et également par
voie aérienne avec nos avions cargo nous
transportons également des produits
pharmaceutiques mais il faut mettre en
place une logistique spéciale parce
qu'il faut garder une certaine
température pour ces produits et donc on
est en train de le faire avec ces
valeurs logistiques et on met en place
tout ce qu'il faut pour que ça se passe
au mieux
l'Afrique est je n'ai pas parlé de
l'Afrique mais c'est un pays un
continent où nous sommes très présents
nous faisons 25% de part de marché sur
le continent africain nous opérons un
port au Nigeria nous opérons un port au
Cameroun on se développe rapidement et
fortement et c'est un continent qui a un
avenir très important donc on se
développe et on est content d'être en
Afrique alors comme dans tous les
continents vous avez des difficultés
mais on essaie de les gérer au mieux
mais c'est un continent qui est
important où nous sommes très présents
merci je vais donner la parole à Ronan
dans PEC oui merci monsieur le Président
de Monsieur le Directeur général je vais
revenir sur la question qu'à poser tout
à l'heure collectabaro concernant
l'intégration de vos émissions au
service des changes de quota européens
qui donc a priori s'annonce quand même
pour 2026
2000-2027 par rapport au dernier
décision du Parlement et de la
commission
ça représente j'ai fait un calcul rapide
si la totalité de vos émissions rentre
dans le système ets c'est de l'ordre de
entre 1 et 2 milliards d'euros par an de
contribution de votre part et notamment
à l'Océane Fendt qui doit récupérer 75%
de Selman qui est quand même assez assez
importante et qui concernerait là tous
les opérateurs européens là il y aura
pas de a priori de problèmes de
concurrence donc moi deux questions
d'abord sur la mise en œuvre du système
donc TSR
comment cela s'annonce-t-il sachant que
sur la mise en place du système ets pour
le transport aérien la Commission
européenne avait dû un moment battre en
retraite par rapport notamment à
l'hostilité chinoise au nom de la
responsabilité commune Méditerranée donc
comment vous voyez aujourd'hui la mise
en place de système sur un temps assez
court parce que 2026 2027 sur des sommes
aussi conséquentes c'est quand même très
très rapides et deuxième question est-ce
que pour vous ce coup est assez facile à
absorber ou est-ce qu'il peut vous poser
des problèmes puisque là on est quand
même seul sur des sommes qui chiffrent
plutôt en milliards et peut-être en
incidente puisque c'est ce que vous avez
présenté en ouverture cette idée d'aller
vers des des carburants de synthèse
neutre en carbone est-ce que vous pensez
vraiment qu'avec un coût de
l'électricité qui est quand même la base
énergétique qui permet la production de
ces carburants un coup d'électricité qui
monte à 200 300 MW
le coût du méga est-ce qu'il est
vraiment raisonnable de penser qu'on
aura un modèle économique pour des
carburants produits avec une électricité
aujourd'hui aussi cher
ce qui est important c'est que
aujourd'hui de nombreuses actions seront
entreprises concernant la protection de
l'enversonnement donc nous en tant que
transporteur maritime transporteur
aérien on est rentré aussi comme nos
concurrents dans ce schéma là et c'est
tant mieux d'ailleurs des fois
pataugeois évident de comprendre comment
ça va se passer est-ce que les échéances
ne sont pas trop courtes est-ce qu'on va
être en mesure de délivrer en temps et
en heure on fera tout pour et je pense
que c'est important et je parlais des
nouvelles normes environnementales qui
commencent à intervenir à partir de de
janvier 2023 ça englobe également cette
problématique là les montants sont
colossaux
à la fin qui va payer je pense que ça
sera un sujet qu'il faudra voir avec nos
clients
mais je comprends tout ce qui se met en
place on n'a pas le choix on voit
comment la planète est en souffrance
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on soit
parmi les
leaders dans ce domaine de la protection
de l'environnement il y a une série de
mesures qui est en train d'être mise en
place il y en a tellement que des fois
on est un peu perdu sur ce qu'il faut
une fois pas faire mais en tout cas on
n'a pas le choix et on fera et comme je
vous disais on a des navires on était
les premiers à avoir des navires
propulsés au gaz naturel qui est fier ce
n'est que 20% mais c'est déjà un
avantage par rapport à ces
problématiques là mais il faut continuer
à progresser et à avancer
oui merci beaucoup j'aurais voulu
évoquer avec vous le problème du conflit
ukrainien et l'accessibilité ou
l'inaccessibilité de la mer Noire
est-ce que ça a des conséquences pour
vous-même pour votre compagnie et
quelques
comment vous la compensez pour que
justement le marché des exportations
notamment de ces pays puisse se faire
tout d'abord on regrette ce qui se passe
en Ukraine c'est une situation qui est
quand même dramatique aux portes de
l'Europe
nous sommes comme je le disais dans mon
dans mon discours nous transportons pas
de blé nous transportons pas de pétrole
et pas de gaz mais depuis le début du
conflit nos navires nescale plus en
Russie et des scale plus en Ukraine
donc ce qui fait que
nous à partir de là bien sûr qu'il y a
des volumes qu'on a plus aborder nos
bateaux mais c'est des volumes qui
restent quand même relativement faibles
tant au niveau de la Russie au niveau de
l'Ukraine
donc on a
mis les on a fait ce qu'il fallait pour
stopper nos desserts en Russie et en
Ukraine et également nos investissements
même si nos parts de marché en Russie et
en Ukraine reste modérée
merci je vais donner la parole à
Guillaume chevrolier merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président
Directeur Général à ce stade de
l'audition vous avez déjà répondu à très
nombreuses questions je voudrais revenir
sur deux thèmes vous qui êtes un
représentant d'une entreprise familiale
leader mondial français entreprise
patriotes vous l'avez dit vous avez une
politique de RSE responsabilité sociale
environnementale environnement social et
gouvernance à de nombreuses reprises
vous avez évoqué vos engagements en
matière environnementale ce que vous
pouvez préciser d'autres engagements en
matière de préservation de la
biodiversité vous avez parlé du climat
vous avez
parlé d'autres engagements sur la
biodiversité et votre perception sur la
RSE par rapport à l'attractivité de vos
métiers et des difficultés éventuelles
de recrutement que vous pouvez avoir on
sait que beaucoup d'entreprises en ont
vous avez un rayonnement international
est-ce que vous le fait d'avoir cette
RSE est un atout un levier
et le deuxième sujet que je vais aborder
il vient d'être évoqué par une collègue
c'est votre présence sur les cinq
continents et particulièrement sur le
continent africain qui a un fort
potentiel vous venez de indiquer que
vous aviez des investissements
quels sont est-ce que vous pouvez
développer là aussi les investissements
que vous souhaitez faire sur le
continent votre évaluation du potentiel
du continent africain et la différence
que vous pouvez avoir vous pouvez faire
entre les différentes zones du continent
africain puisque il est vaste et la
place de l'Afrique francophone dans vos
projets sur ce continent là en
particulier merci
de manière générale depuis quelques mois
aujourd'hui recruter devient difficile
parce que le marché de l'emploi est très
tendu que vous soyez en France ou
ailleurs à l'étranger vous avez
pratiquement les mêmes difficultés
partout donc là on a des difficultés
deuxièmement avoir une vraie stratégie
RSE et un élément important pour la
personne qui veut nous rejoindre c'est
même plus pour nous c'est le
collaborateur va nous demander avant de
prendre sa décision est-ce que vous avez
une stratégie RSE et est-ce que vous
pouvez m'expliquer et donc ce qui fait
que oui on a une stratégie RSE oui on
fait beaucoup de choses tant au niveau
de l'environnement mais également au
niveau de l'activité de la Fondation
d'entreprise CMA CGM on vient en aide à
des populations défavorisées on a un
projet sur l'éducation en Afrique et
également on aide les familles qui ont
été touchées
l'explosion du 4 août 2020 au Liban et
également dans les quartiers difficiles
de Marseille donc par rapport à ça oui
on a une stratégie RSE ambitieuse et il
faut qu'elle continue à l'être parce que
les problèmes malheureusement sont
tellement importants dans ce monde qu'il
faut qu'on continue à oeuvrer les
entreprises à essayer d'aider surtout
pour ceux qui ont les moyens de le faire
pour ce qui concerne l'Afrique
c'est un continent ou à nouveau on est
très présent on a développé un
incubateur de start-up qui ouvrira ses
portes à Abidjan en Côte d'Ivoire dans
les prochains mois donc je pense que
au-delà du transport maritime au-delà de
la logistique il y a un terreau fertile
pour tout ce qui concerne le digital et
je souhaite à tout prix qu'on soit qu'on
soit présent donc par rapport à ça on
est présent on est très présent en
Afrique de l'Ouest on est très présent
en Afrique de l'Est et on est présent en
Afrique du Nord on a des parts de marché
en Algérie au Maroc et en Tunisie qui
sont importantes au même titre qu'on les
a en Tanzanie aux Mozambique et ailleurs
en Afrique de l'Est on a fait des
opérations de croissance externe en
Tanzanie on a acheté une petite société
de logistique on en a acheté une
deuxième donc c'est un secteur qu'on
souhaite développer c'est un secteur qui
est en pleine croissance qui a des
difficultés mais où le groupe CMA CGM
est très présent tant sur la logistique
que sur le maritime sur le marit on a
des services au départ d'Afrique de
l'Ouest à destination du nord de
l'Europe on a des services au départ
d'Asie à destination de l'Afrique de
l'Est donc on est vraiment présent
depuis de nombreuses années date en 2005
on a fait l'acquisition de Delmas qui
nous a permis de sécuriser des parts de
marché depuis on a développé on a
sécurisé un terminal
au Cameroun qui s'appelle le terminal de
Kribi à quelques heures de Douala on est
également opérateur d'un terminal à côté
de
l'agos au Nigeria qui s'appelle l'équipe
donc on est vraiment présent on est
présent au Maroc on appelle le terminal
de Tanger on est on opère interminal à
Casablanca donc c'est des zones où le
groupe CMA CGM est présent dans ce le
transport maritime que la logistique on
ne fait pas d'aérien pour le moment mais
on fait beaucoup de maritimes et de
logistique
alors je pense que pour la commission
des affaires économiques ça sera la
dernière intervention parce que je n'en
ai pas relevé d'autres et je donne la
parole à un mètre gaquerre
si beaucoup monsieur le Président
Directeur Général tout d'abord merci
pour cette présentation et toutes mes
félicitations pour ce parcours assumer
et puis lorsqu'on entend vos engagements
en termes d'innovation de recherche sur
la logistique de demain je pense que la
saga est loin d'être terminée
deux questions très courtes la première
bon j'ai compris que vous aviez un
certain affran parlé j'aimerais savoir
si vous vous fixez des limites dans
votre développement
en matière de type de collaboration de
rachats de produits
voilà à transporter ça c'est ma première
question et puis la deuxième vous avez
évoqué pas mal de pistes de
recommandations sur l'amélioration de
nos ports de notre de notre transport de
notre transport maritime est-ce que vous
travaillez est-ce que vous êtes en
contact avec les membres de notre
gouvernement est-ce que vous l'avez été
merci
[Musique]
je la première question le point le plus
important c'est le groupe CMA CGM c'est
150000 collaborateurs et des
collaborateurs de très grands niveaux et
donc aujourd'hui j'aime bien leur dire
que
le ciel et la limite
du moment qu'on bénéficie d'une équipe
de grands professionnels et qu'on a les
moyens je ne vois pas pourquoi je
m'arrêterai
si j'ai pas les moyens je m'arrêterai
nécessairement mais aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on se développe beaucoup
on a les moyens de se développer et on a
des moyens humains qui nous permettent
de se développer là et à nouveau je
salue les collaborateurs du Groupe
CMA-CGM qui m'accompagne depuis de
nombreuses années et qui sont des
collaborateurs formidables maintenant la
deuxième question vous parliez peut-être
si vous pouvez la reposer la question
concernant le deuxième sujet ma question
elle est assez précise c'est de savoir
si aujourd'hui vous les recommandations
les conseils les préconisations que vous
faites en termes de développement de nos
propres ports ici en France
elles sont aujourd'hui soumises aux
membres de notre gouvernement si vous
avez eu l'occasion de travailler sur
plusieurs repris vous avez évoqué vous
êtes mis à notre disposition pour
échanger sur vos suggestions est-ce que
c'est le cas aujourd'hui avec les
membres du gouvernement ce que ça a été
le cas sur le mandat précédent et est-ce
que c'est envisagé prochainement nous
avons de très bonnes relations avec le
gouvernement on est souvent en
discussion sur des sujets importants et
le dialogue est très positif donc par
rapport à ça
d'ailleurs sur certains opérations qu'on
a réalisé on les a réalisé en bon
intelligence avec le gouvernement avec
qui on a d'excellentes relations
c'est assez cash comme réponse non
bien merci la parole est à Rémy merci
monsieur le Président et merci monsieur
le Président Directeur Général de
prendre le temps de de répondre avec à
la fois beaucoup de précision et avec un
esprit de synthèse très très fort moi je
voulais simplement parler de tout ce
qu'on appelle l'énergie renouvelable
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure
les biocarburants le
biométhane et vous n'avez pas évoqué
l'hydrogène vert dans vos propos et je
suis surpris parce que quand on parle de
transport de marchandises que ce soit en
poids lourd ou en
transport ferroviaire on a l'impression
quand même que l'hydrogène vert sera
l'avenir de l'énergie renouvelable pour
ses qualités de 0 carbone donc
quelle piste vous avez dans ce domaine
là est-ce que vous travaillez sur
l'hydrogène vert pour le transport
maritime
pas beaucoup parce que je n'y crois pas
beaucoup
les
et je parle au niveau des navires
conteneur on fait beaucoup de on regarde
sur la partie logistique et notamment
sur les camions on regarde des solutions
à l'hydrogène mais pour ce qui concerne
les bateaux porte-conteneur il faudrait
des batteries énormes pour pouvoir
propulser notre très grand bateau alors
on pourrait dire peut-être que
l'hydrogène pourrait être utilisé pour
des bateaux de plus petites tailles qui
relie qui font des traversées plus
courtes peut-être mais le coût risque de
d'être prohibitif donc c'est pour ça
qu'on a plutôt mis l'accent sur les
énergies de synthèse se le GNL et pour
ce qui concerne la logistique oui sur la
logistique on regarde parce qu'on opère
une flotte de camion on regarde des
camions à l'hydrogène oui ça c'est des
sujets qu'on regarde mais je les regarde
moi sur la partie maritime
merci merci en visio je vais donner la
parole à Nassima d'un Dar
Nassima
je ne sais pas si vous m'entendez parce
que moi je suis en visio je voulais
remercier général soit sa présentation
il le sait mieux que moi et les
territoires ultramarins sont fortement
dépendants du transport maritime et je
sais que le groupe CMA CGM a beaucoup
investi même sur la Réunion et nous
sommes aussi très triboutaire du
transport aérien puisque la majorité de
nos produits de nos consommations
viennent de l'exploitation donc moi je
voulais saluer le geste qu'avait fait
votre société sur la baisse des 500
euros sur une durée de un an pour que
pour diminuer le coût du frais des
transports de marchandises dans les
domaines et je voulais voir si vous avez
vous envisagez d'autres possibilités
d'aide par rapport justement à l'aérien
je sais que vous avez investi dans Air
France qui est aussi une très grande
entreprise et je veux saluer cet
investissement pour pour
Air France alors sur l'investissement
des ports principalement français vous
avez évoqué toute la possibilité de
moderniser les infrastructures celui du
port de La Réunion j'avais une question
sur la piste
d'un triangle entre les ports de l'île
Maurice celui de la Réunion et celui de
Tamata puisque vous avez évoqué les
investissements que vous faites en
Afrique moi je voulais surtout vous
poser la question sur toute la zone
Océan Indien avec la proximité du canal
de Mozambique qui est juste à côté et
puis le port très très influent celui de
Tamatave à Hamada parce que Madagascar
est une île très prometteuse également
pour la France et qui pourrait être un
centre de production textile par exemple
au cas où les industries ne voulaient
pas être totalement dépendant de la
Chine donc je voulais avoir votre point
de vue par rapport à cette zone de
l'océan Indien et des possibilités
effectivement du trafic maritime dans
cette zone principalement via la
Commission de l'Océan Indien la COI et
le rôle que la France a chez nous à
travers justement le territoire français
et européen que représente la Réunion
merci pour votre réponse monsieur le
Président et merci à vous merci à vous
pour nous la le port de La Réunion et la
plateforme de transbordement pour
l'océan Indien et nous opérons
aujourd'hui le port de La Réunion donc
c'est un port qui est très important
pour nous ou à partir de la Réunion on
éclate sur Madagascar et et sur les
Maldives les Seychelles et autres
îles de l'Océan Indien donc pour nous la
Réunion joue un rôle majeur on y est
présent depuis de nombreuses années on
opère le terminal de la réunion et on
continuera à se développer donc surtout
que la croissance très forte dans cette
partie du monde et en étant à la Réunion
vous êtes un peu au centre géographique
de tout ce qui se passe dans la zone et
on a choisi la Réunion plutôt que de
choisir l'île voisine
je pensais que j'avais terminé la
commission des affaires économiques mais
Daniel grémillier qui a du repartir en
visio souhaite poser une question très
courte Mathilde
Daniel est-ce que tu nous entends
tant pis
on va donner la parole maintenant à
Gilbert Favreau et puis on vous donnera
la parole à s'il est arrivé
sur le mets ton micro entendez dire tout
à l'heure que vous considérez que la
gestion des ports français était une
bonne gestion les ports français ont
souvent été agités par des mouvements
sociaux
les personnes qui qui procèdent soit au
déchargement soit au chargement des
bateaux ont quelquefois provoquer de
grosses difficultés pour nous ports
maritimes est-ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre dans vos propos
ces problèmes font que les ports
français demeurent attractifs pour
les affréteurs ou les transporteurs
comme vous
comme je l'ai dit je la gestion des
ports français qui soit en outre-mer en
métropole est bonne la difficulté qu'on
a connu avec la crise du covid a montré
qu'on saturé très facilement les
infrastructures portuaires donc il y a
des investissements à faire pour que ces
saturations qu'on a connu liées au covid
et à une demande extrême ne revienne pas
donc la gestion est bonne mais par
contre on a pu voir qu'avec les volumes
que doivent traiter maintenant ces ports
français et ça s'applique à tous les
ports du monde vont devoir être revus et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
réflexion à un moment donné sur comment
on fait pour augmenter la taille de
certains ports français comment on fait
pour augmenter les zones de stockage de
certains ports français pour qu'on ne se
retrouve pas dans des situations ou des
bateaux attendent une dizaine de jours
avant de pouvoir rentrer faute de main
d'oeuvre faute de place hacker faute de
manque de camionneur donc je dirais
c'est plutôt ces sujet là que la gestion
de terminale lui-même mais il y a des
investissements importants à faire et il
faudra qu'il y ait une discussion à un
moment donné avec les pouvoirs publics
sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait et comment on
fait
alors Daniel gremière est revenu donc si
vraiment tu peux faire très court et
après Laurent saumon pareil parce que je
pense que quand même monsieur le
Président Directeur Général n'a pas
ménagé son temps là
on ne t'entend pas
voilà
vous m'entendez là
avec mes excuses là j'ai dû vous quitter
et jouer demander d'abord merci beaucoup
à Monsieur président directeur général
une question très rapide
le rôle a important que vous pouvez
jouer dans la des carbonation au niveau
du transport vous n'avez pas évoqué
d'hydrogène est-ce que alors qu'on sait
que l'hydrogène comme par rapport aux
Daniel ça a été évoqué excusez-moi
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
a déjà répondu cette question
oui juste une petite question d'avoir
merci beaucoup donc je vais droit au but
puisque vous investissez dans le
transport aérien dans la logistique
est-ce que vous voyez un avenir dans les
liaisons intérieures justement pour
cette logistique en France sachant qu'il
y a des petits aéroports qui a une
développement d'un logistique
d'anthropologie un peu partout sur le
territoire est-ce que vous voyez un
développement dans le cadre de votre
entreprise et de vos investissements
bien sûr et d'ailleurs l'investissement
qu'on fait dans Colis Privé nous donne
la possibilité d'offrir le dernier
kilomètre en France était un secteur qui
se développe le secteur de l'e-commerce
se développe fortement et donc ce qui
fait que oui bien sûr bien sûr et on
envisage différents développements
merci je vais donner la parole à
Laurence Muller Braun merci Monsieur le
Directeur Général pour cette exposé très
intéressant
nous avons bien entendu vos engagements
dans votre politique
environnementale sociale ou patriote
comme vous l'avez dit et elle est a
saluée bien sûr je me posais la question
est-ce que vous avez aussi un regard tel
en amont et en aval c'est à dire chez
vos fournisseurs les chantiers navals
qui construisent vos bateaux ceux qui
construisent vos containers est-ce qu'il
y a un regard justement de politiques
sociales de politiques environnementale
et en aval c'est à dire le recyclage de
tout les navires cargo des containers
pareil on peut avoir une politique
sociale particulière puisque souvent
tous ces toutes ces activités ont lieu
dans des pays
entre guillemets en voie de
développement ou les lois sociales ne
sont pas les mêmes et surtout le le
tracé du recyclage n'est pas le mais pas
aussi exigeant merci
et évidemment
nous étudiants nos fournisseurs avec
lesquels on travaille et nous
fournisseurs doivent respecter certaines
règles et donc il est évident que s'il
ne respecte pas les règles qui sont
aussi liées à l'environnement dans ce
cas là on travaillera pas avec eux donc
la politique au niveau de
l'environnement est très forte et très
présente chez nous et je ne l'ai pas
cité dans mon propos tout à l'heure mais
on a même décidé de ne plus transporter
de plastique de déchets de plastique
abandonné un navire porte-conteneur
depuis le 1er juin
et nous sommes les seuls
bien monsieur le Président Directeur
Général un grand merci pour la clarté de
vos propos
un grand merci pour
cocorico qui nous va bien et puis merci
pour vos réponses je crois que vous avez
pu voir que ce débat intéressait
l'ensemble des sénateurs de la
commission des Affaires d'économique et
de la commission d'aménagement du
territoire puisqu'ils ont été nombreux à
être présent aujourd'hui et puis je vais
te laisser conclure merci pour
effectivement nous avons rejoint et puis
merci surtout pour avoir répondu
franchement et on a bien compris qu'en
matière de développement et
d'investissement tant que vous pourrez
et que vous avez vous pourrez saisir des
opportunités vous le ferez et on peut
s'en réjouir merci
je voudrais le nom de la présidente de
la commission des affaires économiques
et de l'ensemble de mes collègues qui
sont membres cette commission vraiment
très sincèrement vous remercier d'avoir
accepté pour la première fois de vous
prêter à cet exercice c'était une
audition je peux vous dire une première
mais une audition qui a été non
seulement bien sûr particulièrement
intéressantes et le nombre des questions
qui vous ont été posées en porte
témoignage mais c'était aussi une
audition que vous avez parfaitement
réussi par votre disponibilité que nous
avait consacré plus de deux heures de
votre temps merci encore vraiment du
fond du coeur par votre rigueur par la
clarté de vos propos et j'espère en tout
cas que vous reviendrez avec plaisir au
Sénat après avoir passé avec brio cette
audition et en tout cas sachez que
vraiment on a été très honoré mais on
est surtout très fiers de compter le
groupe CMA CGM comme étant un des
fleurons français et notre patriotisme
en est tout ragaillardi merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
[Applaudissements]